So, jetzt gucken wir uns mal den angeblichen russischen Battlefield Killer an.
Ich habe das Spiel mir schon mal angeschaut vor zwei Jahren oder so und ich muss sagen,
ich habe da nicht allzu viel eines Battlefield Killers erkannt, aber es gibt ja Leute die behaupten,
dass World War 3 das bessere Battlefield ist. Gut, ich meine das ist bei Battlefield 2042 auch
nicht schwer, aber das Spiel war ja schon am Start bevor es Battlefield 2042 überhaupt gegeben hat.
So, ups. Und danach gucken wir uns den aktuellen Battlefield Patch an und spielen vielleicht
paar Runden oder was heißt vielleicht relativ sicher. Eins, zwei Runden vielleicht auch mehr
wenn es Bock macht Battlefield, aber ich fürchte da wird nicht allzu viel gefixt.
Ach Wub Arrive Moment, das mache ich jetzt gerade mal in die in die Sack. Wub Arrive kommt jetzt
direkt in die GIFs rein. Wub Arrive. Das machen wir jetzt gleich, ich mache jetzt die Emotes rein.
Community, oh das ist so verkackt. Partner, ich finde das immer nicht. Emotes, besuchen
sie die Emotes Website. Animierte Emotes. GIF hochladen. Wub Arrive. Schauen wir mal ob es jetzt
funktioniert. Ja, nice, funktioniert. So passt. Das Ding soll heißen Wub Arrive und jetzt sagen wir hochladen.
Wub Arrive ist am Start, probiert mal. Refresh wollen wir, wir refreshen mal Chat. Chat, Chat
Refreshen, hier Refreshen, alles Refreshen. Jetzt probieren wir es gleich nochmal. Also laut Twitch ist es drinne. Wub, Wub, Wub Arrive. Ey! Funktioniert.
Nice. Fock. Wie viele Tabs willst du auf einen Moment, Moment, wenn du denkst das sind viele Tabs.
Wir haben ja noch, wir haben ja noch mehr Tabs, das war es ja noch nicht. Außerdem, ich meine,
ich muss noch meine 32G RAM irgendwie sinnvoll voll kriegen. Wie kommt euch gerade mein aktuelles
Video an? Ich habe das ja vor einer halben Stunde oder so erst freigeschaltet. Ich habe gar nicht
mehr reingeguckt seit einer Weile. Dislike Anzeigen wieder herstellen. Dislike. Die meisten Leute in
Deutschland denken mit dem Dislike, damit SS. Gedisst. Gedisterlike. Das Gedisst, man.
Ich finde es so lustig. Die Leute, die hier, die hier öfters im Stream am Start sind, die fangen
schon immer an, so mein, mein bescheuertes Twitch-Speak zu reden. Ist halt, ist halt schon schlimm,
Alter. Die Stunks gehen hoch für dieses Video, Kappa. Da weißt du, weißt du Bescheid. Da weißt
du Bescheid. Joa, wir müssen es nehmen hier am Start. Gucken wir uns jetzt mal an. Alter, gut,
das kann man zumachen. Ich weiß gar nicht, wo läuft denn die Musik aktuell überhaupt. Leute,
ich mache mal, ich mache mal ein bisschen, ein bisschen was zu hier gerade. Ist vielleicht. Alter,
das Ding kommt überhaupt nicht mehr mit. Ich drücke die ganze Zeit schon Steuerung W. Ihr hört
es vielleicht, aber das ist nicht schnell genug mit Schließen der Tabs. Okay. Wo war denn das
Battlefield-Change-Log? Das hatten wir hier? Nee. Das gucken wir uns dann später an. Jaja,
die Games da. Hier, das da. Hier, Update 2. Da müssen wir dann später mal gucken. Aber jetzt
gucken wir uns erstmal den russischen Battlefield-Killer an. Spoiler, das Letzte,
was ich von dem Game gesehen habe, war halt nicht so der krasse Killer. Und zwar nur so ein bisschen,
das wäre von diesem Game nichts mitgekriegt. Habe ich beobachtet, das ist ja schon eine Weile. Ich
habe das auch vor zwei Jahren oder so schon mal ausprobiert, aber da war noch nicht allzu
viel zu holen. Mal gucken, ob das jetzt besser geworden ist. Ihr seht ja schon, ich habe auch
sagenhafte 76 Minuten Playtime insgesamt schon auf Steam dafür. Also da war wirklich nicht so
viel zu holen. Ich habe es vorhin mal gestartet und geguckt, dass es geht. Oh, was ist? Wollen
die mich verarschen? Ich habe eben noch gespielt. Warum ist... Sagt bloß, die Server sind jetzt
offline. Ich habe eben noch gespielt. Ich habe eben das Game angemacht und habe mich geqt und
habe geguckt, ob alles funktioniert. Also eben vor 45 Minuten oder so. Aber vor 45 Minuten war
der Tweet ja schon raus. Zumindest, also wir gucken uns jetzt mal, bevor wir in das Game reingen,
wir gucken uns jetzt mal zusammen den Closed Beta, das Closed Beta Pax Trailer. Closed Beta?
Was ist denn ein Pax Trailer? Ach Pax, wahrscheinlich Microtransactions oder so. Dass ihr wisst,
was das Game sein möchte und anhand dessen, was ihr gleich dann an Gameplay seht, könnt ihr
beurteilen, ob das Game das auch ist, was es sein möchte. So, einmal Fullscreen. Du sollst
einfach, lass mal das Video einfach nebenbei durchlaufen für mehr View-Stalks. Oh, das ist ja
mal, hör dir das, das ist mal richtig gekommener Style hier.
Also sie machen eindeutig auf Battlefield. Oh, Kilkona ist auch am Start. Also quasi
dieses Video müsste eigentlich heißen Kilkona vs. Kilkona. Svayi, Svayi. Heißt wahrscheinlich
sowas wie Stop Stop oder so. Keine Ahnung. Das heißt sowas wie eigene. Ah, so friendly
quasi. Also es ist offensichtlich, dass Battlefield ihre Vorlage war. Ich mein, ich muss jetzt
mal eins sagen, Zack, ich muss nur, ich finde der Trailer vermittelt tatsächlich einen
besseren Battlefield Eindruck als Battlefield 2049, aber es ist einfach dahingestellt.
Spiel World War 3 auch in 2042. Nee, ich glaub vorher. Okay, wenn das kein Ami ist,
dann weiß ich auch nicht. Der ist so advanced, der hat nicht mal Abzeichen auf der Uniform.
Alle beide nicht. Warum auch immer der das nicht gesehen hat und direkt vor ihn laufen
konnte, keine Ahnung. So, also, das möchte das Spiel sein. Ich will jetzt noch nicht
zu früh was sagen, aber ich hab das Spiel mir mal angeguckt und das letzte Mal war
das äußerst glitchy und langsam. Es hat eigentlich kaum was von diesem Trailer gehabt,
den man da jetzt gesehen hat. Aber probieren wir das mal aus. Das Schlimmste ist, wenn
man das startet, das startet nicht einfach das Game. Es startet erst mal irgendeinen
russischen Launcher, dass das funktioniert und der russische Launcher startet dann, falls
jemand das nicht kennt. Ich wusste auch nicht, dass es das gibt. Mail.ru Anti-Cheat. Kein
Witz, es gibt Mail.ru Anti-Cheat. Also mir war das gar nicht bewusst, dass es Mail.ru
Anti-Cheat gibt. Okay, ich hab mich wirklich überwinden müssen, dass ich auf Accept gedrückt
habe, als mich Mail.ru Anti-Cheat nach Admin-Berechtigung gefragt hat. Der Launcher zählt schon zur Spielzeit,
ja klar, weil sie wusste, dass die gestartet ist. Okay, auch jetzt, probieren wir das mal
aus. Mal gucken, ob Lautstärke passt und überhaupt. Und ob es überhaupt läuft, weil man muss
sagen, die hatten richtig krasse Serverprobleme. Good Game, keine Ahnung. Das letzte Mal,
wo ich es gesehen habe, war es noch äußerst klitschig und kaputt. So, hier richtig, richtig
Kekona-Soldier am Start. Lautstärke scheint ein bisschen laut zu sein. Mach mal kurz ein
bisschen. Ups, nein, nein, nein. Mixer. Mach mal kurz ein bisschen runter. Okay, Quick
Play. Bam. Tactical Ops in Berlin. Dieser Chat ist jetzt deutsch. Nee, ist er ja auch
so auch schon. Tactical Ops, Control. Ah, okay, das ist quasi so Art Conquest. Conquest.
So, Anti-Tank, Assault, Support, Sniper-Man. Also Assault, das Spiel hat keinen Sound oder
Musik. Ich höre einfach gar nichts. Assault, Medic, Pack, Anti-Tank-Mine. Und jetzt ja
hier, technical. Ich weiß nicht mal, was es macht. Oh, okay, es ist immer noch klitschig.
Fällt euch was auf? Weiß nicht, ob euch irgendwas auffällt. Nicht der Recall, dass
du keinen Sound hast beim Schießen. Also keinen eigenen Sound. Au. Okay, nice. Waiting for
players. 37 von 30. Moment, 37 von 30 nötigen Players. Sollte man da nicht davon ausgehen,
dass das Spiel eigentlich jetzt losgeht. Weil nur, vielleicht kann ich auch einfach
nicht gut genug auf Russisch zählen. Oh, jetzt habe ich den gehittert. Okay, wir stellen
es jetzt einfach mal irgendwo hin und gucken, ob wir Gegner sehen. Wohlgemerkt, die hatten
mehr oder weniger die gleichen Probleme vor zwei Jahren schon. Und angeblich wurde dieses
Spiel jetzt massiv überarbeitet. Sie haben wohl auch den Publisher gewechselt. Oder was
auch immer, mygames.ru oder sowas ist. Und sag mal so, Release ist... Oh, Hi-Rez. Guck
mal, wir haben eine Lampe. Das sind ja die mit Abstand schönsten Reifen, die ich jemals
in einem Game gesehen habe. Liegelung ist da nix. So, wo sind denn die Gegner? Haben
wir vielleicht ein paar Gegner zur Abwechslung? Die killen sich die ganze Zeit selbst. Oh,
es geht los. Es können auch Polen sein. Ich weiß es nicht, ob es Russen oder Polen. Irgendwas
im Osten auf jeden Fall. Der Osten meldet sich zurück. Guck mal, da gibt es einen Tank.
Ach, F muss man drücken. Und jetzt? Ja? Ja? Dazu fällt mir bloß ein. Also, wir haben
keinerlei Sound, wie es aussieht. Sound ist anscheinend schon mal, schon mal broken. Ich
mach das grad mal, ich mach, Leute, ich mach euch hier Mixer. Ich mach euch grad mal wieder
normal laut. Das ihr hört, es gibt eigentlich nix zu hören. Vielleicht hab ich nicht das
Soundpack gekauft. Oh, okay. Schon mal gut, einen Aussteiger, Animationen gibt es nicht.
Okay, wir Captchern. Captchern wir denn? Wo sieht man das? Wir Captchern. Ach, da, das
blaue. Oh, das Captchert ja abfahrklangsam. Nee, guck mal, das geht nach links und rechts
gleichermaßen hoch, das Captchern. Das ist Big Brain-Status-Anzeige. Möglichst kompliziert
gemacht. Und man kann, man kann Lehnstells machen, guckt hier. Ach, wir haben es erobert,
jawoll. Was ist Nachkampf? Gibt es Nachkampf? Das Problem ist ohne Sound irgendwas zu orten
ist natürlich schon Pain's Champ Deluxe. Da guckt er, Pain's Champ Deluxe. Map, haben
wir ne Map? Okay, wir haben ne Map. Das ist schon mal nice, ne Map, wo man auch was erkennt.
Das ist schon mal schön. Wir müssen, aha, wir müssen eigentlich da hinten hin. Okay,
kann man spotten? Nee, kann man X? Marker, X oder so? Ah, hier, Marker setzen geht schon
mal. Nee, ach, doppelt X. Doppelt X für Marker, okay. Ich hab ne Jit, keine Ahnung. Hä,
da ist er doch, dahinter. Auf, gekommen Rit, komm raus. Immerhin hat er cool seinen Helm
verloren. Das ist doch schon mal was. TSM ist am Start. TSM has won Rit. Wart mir nicht,
wie ich da drauf gerade komme. So, gehts hier weiter? Die Frage ist, wo, ah, guck mal, hier,
wir sind schon am Captchern. Massive Captcherstellen. Oh, jawoll, weg, weg mit dem. Easy. Ist da
dead? Ist da dead der Typ, der gecaptchert hat? Nee, der lebt noch. Nice. Aber Leute,
es gibt ein Scoreboard. Seht ihr das? Pog, Pog like this, Alter, Scoreboard. What the,
okay es ist ziemlich dumm ohne Sound, wenn man nicht hört von wo man beschossen wird
und auch nix am Indikator wirklich sieht. Das ist ziemlich dumm. Übrigens ist es mit
dem kaputtenen Sound, war vor zwei Jahren auch schon so in diesem Spielmodus. Hat sich
nicht so viel getan. Orpens, Nee, das ist, man hört auch keine Schritte, das ist wirklich
blöd. Wir spielen mal gleich ne Runde Team Deathmatch. Aber immerhin gibt es nen Ton,
wenn man auf Deploy klickt. Die Maps sind glaub ich der krasseste Camper abfuckts.
Alter, du hörst nichts, du hast keine Schüsse, du hörst keine Schritte. Da fuck, was ist
das denn? Okay, das ist, das ist, das ist wild, wild. Das ist äußerst wild. Vielleicht
hört der ja was, vielleicht ist ja mein Sound nur verbackt. Okay, wo geht hier was, hier?
Next. Tactical Sprint gibt es auch, guck hier, Huge Tactical Sprint. Wir flanken die jetzt,
wir flanken jetzt hier durch und sliden um die Eck. Bin ich kleiner geworden durch Sliden?
Leute, ich bin kleiner geworden durch Sliden, guck mal. Small, Small Soldier, Soldier, jetzt.
Achso, man muss Space drücken um wieder aufzustehen, rekt, Next. Der crouched immer noch, ja, war
es natürlich sehr merkwürdig. Au, von wo? Okay, ich seh hier nichts. Hier drinnen hat
es geschossen, guck mal, habt ihr das gesehen? Hier gibt es zu viele, hier gibt es definitiv
viel zu viele Ecken wo was abgehen könnte. Hier kann es ja wirklich an jeder Ecke abcampen.
Tja, von wo ist halt die Frage? Gräb'nhaus Stels. Hier geht es nicht weiter, alles klar.
Oh, guck mal, RPGs am Start. Okay, springen Stels geht nicht. Es ist aber wirklich dumm
ohne Sound. Hab ich ne Granate? Oh hier, Massive Nades. Wir sind doch hinter diesem komischen
Auto hier gewesen, oder? Was? Ah, Q ist nicht hinlegen. Was ist hinlegen? Äh, X? Ne. Okay,
keine Ahnung. Ich hab legit keine Ahnung von wo mich was getroffen hat. Von wo? Kann
man hier irgendwie aus dem Fenster schießen, oder? Ach, der hier. Komplette Überforderung.
Es ist auch echt, wir, es ist wirklich hart, hart, wir hier. Okay, drei ist heal. Nice.
Ich verpiss mich mal. Ah, hier ist nix, okay. Vielleicht müssten wir... Okay, so kann
man hier auf jeden Fall nicht schießen über Range. Wahrscheinlich muss man hier Singelschuss
machen, dass man trifft. In der Mitte ist auch einer, oder? Okay, springen, schießen
geht nicht, hab ich grad festgestellt. Wenn man springt, kann man nicht schießen. Es
piepst, Leute. Hört ihr das auch? Ganz eklig piepsen. Jetzt ist weg. Aber ohne Sound ist
schon ganz schön beschissen, Mann. Also guck mal, wenn man springt, kann man... Hä? Ne,
wenn man springt, kann man nicht schießen, ne? Restart mal das Game. Ne, das ist normal
in dem Modus, dass der Sound kaputt ist. Guck mal, es gibt sogar Metro. Was ist das deutsche
Ansage? Oh, die Map ist ja riesig, Mann. Also riesig verwinkelt. Nicht unbedingt von der
reinen Fläche, aber insgesamt ist die Map ja riesig. Ich hab keinen Plan. Wo lasert
mich hier irgendwas? Okay. Okay, das Game ist, wir bleiben einfach sitzen und gucken
in eine Richtung. Das ist schon mal nice. Wenn ich jetzt krasser Rainbow Six Pro wäre,
würde ich quasi so rumlaufen. Ne, warte mal, wie laufen die Rainbow Six Leute immer so?
Ach, keine Ahnung. Die haben doch so einen super geilen Rainbow Six Stels. Okay. Metro,
Metro. Ich muss in der Metro sporen. Ach ja, man kann übrigens am Sprint nicht direkt
schießen, wie ihr gerade gesehen habt. Okay, hier muss man wirklich ein bisschen langsamer
sein, glaub ich. Hey, die haben Native Speaker Ansagen. Das klang nicht wie in den Russen,
man versucht Deutsch zu sprechen. Nice, okay. Ob wir captchern das gerade? Wie legt man
sich denn hin? C? Control ist es auch nicht? C? Weiß nicht. Aber wir haben es doch gleich
gecaptchert. Von Recht hab ich irgendwas schießen gehört. Okay, ah jetzt haben wir es, jetzt
haben wir es, okay. Ist über uns ein Panzer? Alles klar, oder auch nicht. Wie viele Spieler
sind das eigentlich? Ach, sind kaum Gegner drinnen. Der Tactical Sprint ist immer noch
verbuggt, da geht mal, mal geht da nicht. Sehr merkwürdig. Nee. Okay, das ist immer,
ach ich krieche immer noch, stimmt. Ja, das ist Fail. Das ist Fail mit dem Griechen. Ich
glaube es gibt keine Claymores oder irgendwelche Dinger. Stellt euch mal diese Maps noch mit
Claymores vor. Dann ist es doch komplett vorbei. Nice. Next. Oh, ergeblich ist hier was. Hä?
Pointstack, guckt euch das mal an. Mein Pointstack hört gar nicht mehr auf. 2000 Punkte, es
gehört, guck mal, es hört nicht auf. Es, es, es stackt einfach, das ist wie, das ist
tatsächlich in dem Fall wie in alten Battlefields. Also ohne Schusssound ist tatsächlich, oh,
oh, lul, ich habe ihn gekillt. Einfach mal in die Richtung gesprayed. Wassermelone ist
am Start. Einfach in die Richtung gesprayed, lul. Komm, ich stelle es jetzt mit unserem
Typ davor. Es fühlt sich aber richtig schwerfällig und, und. Okay, die Typen können nicht wirklich
weit Granaten werfen. Hä? Na gut, das Schöne für mich ist, das Schöne für mich ist,
die haben auch keinen Sound, alle. Okay, was war das, drei? Midi-Pack, Midi-Pack. Alter,
heil dich, heil dich, der Typ ist immer noch im Fenster oben. Ich habe einen Killstreak,
guck mal, ich kann jetzt einen Air-Strike holen, aber dafür habe ich nicht genug Punkte, oder?
So, ist der Typ immer noch oben im Fenster? Und welches Fenster ist es überhaupt? Und
warum klingeln hier so viele Telefone? Ey, das Spiel ist so, das ist das krasseste
gekommen und game, was ich je gespielt habe. Der Atmen, wir sollen leise ballern, ich habe
nicht mal Sound beim Ballern. Von wo? Von hier? Von hier? Nee. Von wo? Das ist ein Air-Strike?
Kann ich auch einen Air-Strike holen? Hui! Äh, A2. Nee, wo sind wir? Was ist das hier,
Zack? Das ist C1. Nee, ich mache da keinen Air-Strike. Okay, campen wir mal uns ein bisschen
am Fenster noch ab. Da war er. Guck mal, da hat mich, die anderen haben mich gesehen.
Oh, wow, wow, wow. Oh, meine Ammo ist leer. Pants-Man, der Pants-Man kriegt jetzt einen
Air-Strike. C1, Panzer. Keine Ahnung, gibt es, gibt es Kriege, kann ich mir Ammo da raus
nehmen oder? Stirbt man, wenn man da runterfällt, bestimmt. Au, nee. Oh, das fühlt sich äußerst,
also sehr, sehr, jetzt, jetzt kriegen wir einen Air-Strike. Bam, Air-Strike, 7. Nee,
da wird schon gerade ein Air-Strike. Da, da geht er hin. Da geht er jetzt hin, der Air-Strike.
Oh, oh, auf den Panzer, der Pants-Man, Leute, der Pants-Man. Bam. Geiler Air-Strike. Nicht
so satisfying, nicht so satisfying Air-Strike. Das klingt wie das Griechen. Okay, man sollte
in dem Game nicht über freie Felder laufen, das habe ich schon gecheckt. Guck mal, so
viele gekommen sind auf einem, auf einem Haufen. Oh, von wo, von wo? Da, oh nee, meine Muni
ist leer. Jetzt wird gerusht, Leute. Jetzt wird gerusht. Kann man, kann man das aufheben?
Okay. Der Camera-Shake beim Laufen, ja, es fühlt sich sehr, sehr träge und, und klitschig
an, also im Prinzip so wie vor zwei Jahren, wo ich es mal ausprobiert habe. Ripp. Geh
mal bei MikeyDog rein. Der macht das gut, der sitzt hier schön im Häuschen und bewegt
sich nett. MikeyDog. Das Hit-Feedback ist halt auch nicht so das geilste. Das Hit-Feedback
ist auch bisschen merkwürdig. Achtung, Massive-Nade. Bin mir nicht ganz sicher, wo wir hingucken,
wo wir jetzt hin können. Hier, Reinslide-On. Jawoll. Massive-Flight-Action. Komm, flanken,
Massive-Flank. Die wissen noch nicht, dass wir hier sind. Pack. Enemy-Hit 91. Wie, das
war kein Kill? Alter, da hat nur der Cop rausgeguckt. Der Waffensound, den gibt's nicht. Waffensound
ist overrated, outdated, debated, den braucht man nicht. Die haben sich gedacht, Waffensound
ist zu OP. Waffensound ist nicht notwendig für ein Game. Also ohne Waffensound ist tatsächlich
echt hängen geblieben. Und auch dieses Hinlegen und so. Ne, ne. Was ist hier? Angeblich geht's
hier voll ab, ich seh nix. Alles klar. Leckt. Boah, es leckt. Krass, haben wir eine gute
Verbindung angeblich schon. Alter, beweg dich, man. Also die ganze Bewegung, da müssen sie
auf jeden Fall noch was dran machen. Das fühlt sich nicht schwerfällig an. Wenn ihr was
schwerfällig sehen wollt, dann spielt Halo. Halo spielt sich zwar schwerfällig, aber
bei Halo fühlst du dich so wie Herr der Lage, was hier nicht so ist. Ich muss mal gucken,
kann man jetzt hier irgendwie peeken oder so? Irgendwas hab ich gekillt. So, wir peeken,
wir peeken da. Einer lebt doch da noch. Oh, meine Ammo ist schon wieder leer. Also da
müssen sie auf jeden Fall noch irgendwas machen. Das fühlt sich nicht... Kann ich hier was
rausnehmen? Request, hier, warte, Request. Request, Gadget Use. Ja, ja, ich will Ammo
haben. Gib her, gib Ammo. Pog, Ehrenmann hier, guckt euch an. Hallo? Mehr geht nicht. Richtig
Ehrenmann hier. Mickey, alter. Jawoll. Jetzt hab ich, jetzt hab ich was, aber von hinten
wäre weggestellt. Okay. Kann man Klassen wechseln? Equipment Anti-Tank. Hä, ich bin
Anti-Tank? Das ist doch keine... Die Waffe, die ich hab, sieht anders aus als das. Ich
bin Assault. Ich will Anti, ich will das hier spielen. Ne. Anti-Tank, Character? Oh Leute,
habt ihr es gesehen? Man kann Squads wechseln. Sachen gibt's, es gibt Spiele, die haben tatsächlich
noch sowas Basic-mäßiges wie Squads wechseln drin. Oh, oh. The Forsen Troll. Oh, oh, Toss.
Es gibt wenige Schimpfwörter, die ich kenne, so auf Russisch, aber das war Toss. Das war
definitiv Toss. Ist das ein Gegner? Ne. Ich hab keine Ahnung wo... Alter Mann. Hab ich
den gekillt? Ne, oder? Was ein Gestellte, Mann. Das ist glaub ich kein Game für mich. Das
ist mir dann doch ein bisschen zu langsam. Okay, kommen wir hier raus? Oh, da ist was.
Oh ne, das ist ein gegnerischer Panzer. Okay, das war 1A Headshot. Direkt Down Gegner. Treffer,
Treffer, Feedback nicht vorhanden. Wallbang. Alter. Der Typ. Lul. Lul. Alter, die lassen
sich ja wegspringen wie sonst was hier. Man hört halt nichts. Man hört keine Schritte
und nichts. Das ist extremst irritierend. Und auch das Move ist so laggy. Okay, ich
will mich mal nicht beschweren, das Ding ist Beta und alles, aber es spielt sich nicht
wirklich gut. Ich könnte mir aber vorstellen, wenn sie das auf die Reihe kriegen, ist das
so ein bisschen Taktik, FPS, mit Battlefield-Einschlag. Wirklich viel Battlefield sehe ich jetzt
weder beim Moveman noch bei anderen Sachen. Ich mein es geht Panzer oder so. Also richtig
viel Battlefield ist da nicht dabei. Aber es ist so ein bisschen Taktik. Taktik stellt
es mit Battlefield-Anleihen. Das stelle ich mir gar nicht mal so schlecht vor. Wieso fliegen
Granaten, als würde man tote Forelle schmeißen? Ich weiß nicht, das sind super krasse Elite-Soldaten,
die können das halt nicht besser. Du meinst heute das Game ist traurig, was die auf Russisch
sprechen oder du meinst aktuell ist Battlefield traurig mit russischen Sprüchen? Weil die
müssten eigentlich theoretisch richtig nice russisches Voice Acting haben, weil die kommen
aus Polen und ich glaube die haben bestimmt auch viele Entwickler aus Russland. Ach BF2124,
also die hier müssten das eigentlich ganz gut hinkriegen. Aber die haben auch bei den
Durchsagen in der U-Bahn richtig deutsche Sprecher gehabt. Guck mal wir haben jetzt
M14, äh nicht M14, M417. MSBSK. Holosight, jawoll. Next. Lobby. Wir gucken mal, vielleicht
können wir das schon, ach guck mal jetzt haben wir das Holosight schon drauf. Hatte
das alles automatisch Attached? Jetzt sind wir in Warschau. Oder, oder, nee. Ist das
überhaupt Warschau oder ist das Kriegsäge? Ist das Warschau oder ist das die Kriegsäge?
Moment, ich weiß, dass ich das anlockt hab, das müsst ihr mir nicht nochmal zeigen. Die
Gesichtsanimation ist tatsächlich, das könnte man in der Tat eins zu eins eigentlich hier
so rein machen. Es sieht wirklich äußerst Gang-Wade-mäßig aus. Ah jetzt sind wir in
Moskau. Jetzt sind wir quasi, so, ja was denn jetzt Game? Kriege ich jetzt einfach immer
Level geschenkt für nicht spielen? Ok Customize. Guck mal was wir hier machen können. Anti-Tank
Equipment, nee Assault. Assault hatten wir von den Dingern. Ok. MSBSK Default. Und da
können wir jetzt unser Zeug Attachchen? Nee. Iron Sight, Secondary Sight. Ich hab doch,
ich hab doch eben irgendeinen Holosight unlockt, hat er mir gesagt. Welches Holosight hab ich
denn unlockt? Irgendwie glaube ich, dass es verbackt ist. Body Parts? Was für Body Parts?
Ah Stock und Griff und so, ok. Aber wo ist denn? Ok, das ist cool gemacht. Das finde
ich nice. Nee das muss doch die, war das auf der anderen? Ah Moment, ich war ja Anti-Tank.
Sekunde, ich war ja Anti-Tank. Man muss das hierfür gewesen sein. Nee. Das ist nicht
das Holo, was ich unlockt hab. Configs? Customize? Nee. Nee, das ist auch wieder was anderes.
Ich bin verwirrt Leute. Ich hab keine Ahnung, was ich da gerade unlockt habe. Assault. Backpack?
Ach hier ist jetzt im Backpack? Ok, das ist maximal verwirrend. Ich hab nen Rucksack jetzt
mit nem Visier drinnen. Primary, dann glaube Holo. Nee, da haben wir gerade geguckt, da
ist das nicht. Du kannst bei den Visieren den Reiter wechseln. Ah Moment, ich blick
gerade nicht mehr durch. So hier, Customization? Moment, den Skin für nen Visier oder? Primary
Side. Wo kann ich hier was wechseln? Nee, hier kannst du nix wechseln. Oben? Ah, boah.
Ok, ok, das ist Hardcore ohne übersicht. Aber wenn man es weiß, wenn man es weiß, dann
sieht man das. Also dieses Grau auf Schwarz im Hintergrund, das ist wirklich sehr sehr
schwierig zu sehen. Zumal du es auch nicht siehst, dass es überhaupt wechselt von dem
Menü ins Untermenü rein. Ok, Holo Side. Bam, jawoll. Haben wir sonst noch irgendwas?
Secondary Side? Nee, Secondary Side brauchen wir nicht. Under Barrel. Gleich den Noobtube
auspacken. Es gibt nen Skin für nen Magazin. Na gut, da kann man Magazin halt dann lila
machen oder so. Secondary Ammo. Wenn ich kann den ganzen Kram im Shop kaufen für Big Money,
gibt es nen Schalldämpfer? 35. Das ist doch lange Spiele. Nächste gibt es hier? Moment,
wir gucken mal kurz den Shop, Leute. Keine Sorge, ich kauf nix. Ich will nur mal gucken,
was es da gibt. Shop. Ah, Shop ist broken. Shop geht grad nicht, alles klar. Ok, ja dann
Player Banner. Oh, aber ich muss sagen, die Menüs sind unübersichtlich, aber es gibt
wenigstens Sachen zum Einstellen im Vergleich zu Battlefield. Team Formation. Ja, LLV an
Start. Banner. Red Powder. Banner Flag. Ok. Brasilien. Keine Ahnung. Fiji. El Salvador.
Come here. Bam. Dieser Chat ist jetzt deutsch. Alles klar. Quick Play. Auf gehts. Tactical
Ops. In der Kriegssege wieder. Und wie ist WW3? Also ich erkenne ganz gute Ansätze. Es
fühlt sich an wie irgendein Tactical FPS mit Battlefield anleihen. Es ist weniger wirklich
Battlefield. Sag mal, ich hab doch eben Anti-Tank ausgewählt, hab aber Assault gespielt, ne?
Ja. Guck mal, jetzt hab ich mein... Ach, Waiting for Players. Also ich erkenne das
massive Textur. Huge Textures hier. Guckt's euch an. Ah, es lädt noch rein, aber naja.
Da geht noch was. Also ich entdecke Ansätze in dem Game, die ich gar nicht so schlecht
finde. Es ist halt noch sehr groh und das Movement müssen sie auf jeden Fall was dran
machen. Also was mit dem Movement, das fühlt sich einfach falsch an. Vor allem wenn der
Tactical Sprint dann immer nicht funktioniert zwischendurch. Manchmal geht er, manchmal
nicht. 40 für 30 Spiele. Aha, verstehe, verstehe. Vielleicht zählen die da einfach
anders. Vielleicht heißt es 30 von 38 sind ready oder es müssen noch 7 ready werden.
Oder sowas. Oh, wir haben Waffensaugen, Leute. Du musst halten, ausstellen beim Sprinten.
Ah, ok. Controls. Alles klar. Browse. So. Auf Toggle. Ist das jetzt dann Tactical Sprint
da los geht? Probieren wir mal aus. Ja, aber dann macht immer noch kein Tactical Sprint.
Der Tactical Sprint ist ja der hier. Dann musst du es zweimal drücken. Ok, das ist
gewöhnungsbedürftig, ja. Tatsächlich. Da gucken wir mal. So, mal schauen wir die Map.
Es kann man hier hoch. Das würde mich mal interessieren, ob man irgendwie krasse Kletter-Action
machen kann. Nope. Boah, es ruckelt. Es laggt. Das ist Kaufhaus oder sowas. Vielleicht sollte
ich nicht unbedingt mit meinen Leuten hier auf einen Platz stellen. Das ist nicht so
gut. Gehe jetzt runter. Mal Map gucken. Ah, ok. A1 wird gerade gecaptured. Das heißt,
wir gehen jetzt geradeaus und dann links. Die Maps sind, von der Größe her sehen die
schon mal ganz brauchbar aus. Was genau geht mit euch da ab? Von der Größe finde ich
die schon mal relativ brauchbar. Kann man durch? Nope. Ok, Maps sind relativ statisch.
Wir gehen jetzt ans Fenster. Eins habe ich gelernt, nehme immer am Fenster die Leute
auf der Straße weg. Ich bin tot, wenn ich hier rüber laufe. Ich sage es euch. Bin ich
überhaupt richtig, Zack? Wo bin ich auf der Map? Ach, da unten. Ok, wenn ich hier rüber
gehe, dann komme ich direkt bei A1 raus. Ok, wir probieren es. Achtung! Ah, Technik Sprint,
A1. Ah, ok, Pantsman. Da schreit er. Gut, da macht sie jetzt nichts dagegen. Also ich
muss sagen, die Map Größe sagt mir schon mal deutlich mehr zu. Ich finde es ein bisschen
orschverwinkelt. Oh, GG Eatsporn. Also die Map Größe finde ich ein bisschen orschverwinkelt.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall schon mal besser mit Waffensound als die letzte Runde. Wobei
letzte Runde waren wir gar nicht so schlecht. The Clinton. Gibt es Defis? Das wird mich
mal interessieren, ob es Defistells gibt. Ok, wir müssen jetzt den Rainbow-Six-Stells
machen. Hier, da geht es so. Oh ja. Immer schön. The Pantsman. Alter, ich will taktisch
sprinten. Lass mich taktisch... Richtig zuordnen Buff von... What the fuck? Aber die Trefferanzeige
ist tatsächlich... Ok, da hat mir einfach zweimal ins Gesicht geschossen. Aber mein
Team macht das schon. Also Sprinten ist keine gute Idee, merke ich. Sprinten brauchst du
viel zu lang, bis du schießen kannst. Aber ohne Sprinten ist er lahm as fuck. Schießen
die hinten? Oder nicht? Aber man hat ihn gehört, Leute. Der kommt sich jetzt auch mega abgekempt
vor. Haha. Nein. Drei. Heal. Ich brauch ne Granate. Das. War er das?
Oh, was ein Gestellte. Das ist kein Game für mich. Ich sag's euch. Das ist kein Game
für mich. Hier wird so krass gestellst. Ich hör was. Ich bräuchte mal... Haben wir
noch hier was? Ok, ok. Ja, Battlefield und Rainbow Six. Es ist eher Rainbow Six. Es ist
eher Rainbow Six. Ok, mit der Pistole machst du da nichts. Es ist eher Rainbow Six. Features
ein bisschen Battlefield. Ah ja. Da haben wir auch immer ganz gut reingegangen. Da wird
er geslided. Da slided er richtig rein, Gatschi-Buzz. Ok, aber dass der Tactical-Sprint nicht funktioniert,
das fuckt mich ab. Guck mal, das ist so broken. Das Game ist nice, wenn man gerne Ecken abkempt.
Eckenstelles macht. Das ist gut hier. Hallo? Oh, oh, au. Da vorne geht was. Aber eins merkt
man, und das finde ich gut, das finde ich gut, sobald es ein bisschen Tactical und nicht
so Spray and Pray ist, die Leute laufen realistischer, weil normalerweise wird auch keiner hier auf
der Straße laufen, sondern eher an der Wand. Das finde ich schon mal ganz gut. Oh, oh.
Und es hat Friendly Fire. Oh, Tactical-Sprint. Wo sind denn meine Leute jetzt hin? Iron Sides
gegen gerade nicht. Ok, zu hinten über Range ist echt nicht ohne.
Ok, über Range was zu klatschen ist wirklich schwierig.
Ok, Hüfte sprayen ist nicht. Hüfte sprayen ist nicht. Wunder, dass das gut läuft mit
dem Detailgrad. Ich habe alles auf Null. Ich habe alles auf Low. Und es hat ziemliche
Slowdowns zwischendurch, das merkt man auch. Ich habe keinen Plan, wo wir auf der Map sind.
Das sieht für mich alles aus wie eigene Maps. Wo sind wir denn jetzt hier auf einmal? Metro
sind wir jetzt am Start. Metro. Aber ich glaube die Maps lernt man halbwegs mit der
Zeit. Ok, da ist ein anderer Typ. Wir gucken jetzt, ob der hier rein pusht. Der aimt doch
ab. Nee, das sind meine jetzt. So, probieren wir das nochmal hier drinnen, unser Glück.
Ok. Ok. Ich verpiss mich mal wieder. Ich weiß gar nicht vor wo. Ok, da hat er Eckenkug
stills gemacht. Hätte ich auch machen sollen. Kann der länger rutschen als ich? Aber wir
sind ganz gut dabei. Ich glaube, ich glaube, ich sporene gerade bei dem, das war keine,
auf auf auf, du machst das schon. Lass dich nicht von der Seite killen. Was ich, ja, ich
habe vergessen, was ich sagen wollte. Ich glaube, das ist kein Game, wo du mit 35 Kills
am Ende rausgehst oder so. Wirklich nicht. Gehen wir mal kurz hier gucken. Oh. Panzer?
Wenn ich sehe, ob ich da was gesehen habe. Kann man die Granaten vielleicht weiter?
Ich habe nur G gedrückt. Ich habe noch nicht mal abgedrückt. Man kann die nicht halten.
Sobald man G drückt, wirft er die. Ok, das ist. Das ist der Panzer. Der Panzer. Mach
ihn platt. Bäm. Mach ihn kaputt. Jawoll. Oh, das war nice. Das fühlt sich deutlich,
aber mal realistischer an als Battlefield. Das war also taktischer, langsamer, realistischer.
Das ist wirklich ab abfuck. Also das mag ich nicht. Vor allem, dass der tactical Sprint
nie funktioniert. Wenn du ihn bräuchtest. Nehmen wir mal hier Max mit. Jawoll. Und vielleicht
auch mit. Guck mal, wir haben noch Kills. Wir können auch Kills holen. Wo geht hier was?
Ok, alles klar. Was planen die Entwickler so ehrlich gesagt? Keine Ahnung. Können wir
mal gucken. Boah, aber das Movement ist wirklich Pains. Pains Champ. Richtiger Pains Champ.
Richtig Pains Champ Movement, ja. Da oben war ein Gegner. Oh, ich sollte hier weg. Kann
ich jetzt? Ich wollte gerade sagen, ich kann jetzt einen Airstrike darauf machen, aber
jetzt rennen unsere Leute darum. Oh, Airstrike. Direkt hier auf uns. Hä? Ah, Refill. Nice.
A health restore? Ok. Sag mal, sind die über uns? Was ist das? Grenades? Ammo? Ich finde
es auch cool, dass man restocken muss erstmal. Nee, da macht nichts. Kann man hier oben was
ins Fenster werfen? Nee. Interessant. So, wo sind die jetzt? Unter uns? Über uns? Tiefgarage?
Boah, das ist echt, das ist mal richtig unübersichtlich. Ich glaube, das ist eher so ein Game für
Leute, die 5 Minuten stelzen wollen und richtig so outsmarten die Gegner. Für mich ist das
nix. Ich brauche mehr run and gun. Da ist es nur kleine Indie-Company. Ja, so wie Blizzard.
Kann man nicht so viel erwarten, finde ich auch. Capture? Nee, wir capturen C1. Wo gehe
ich denn jetzt am besten hin? Hier ist was, angeblich. Angeblich stellst du dir was.
Von wo? Hier? Boah, das ist ja verwinkelt hoch 3. Das ist ja mal wirklich krass verwinkelt,
das ist echt krass. Wo bin ich überhaupt auf der Map? Da. Okay, dann gehen wir mal
zu A2 jetzt vor. Wahrscheinlich werde ich aus irgendeinem Fenster gebashed jetzt. Moment,
ist hier was? Ah, da hinten ist was. Achtung, Massive-Nade. So, wenn es Spotten gäbe, wäre
cool, aber das ist glaube ich nicht tactical genug hier, das Spotten. Ah, haben wir gehitted?
Meine Muni ist alt. Man darf hier definitiv, ah, tactical sprint, mach tactical sprint.
Man darf nicht so viel sprayen. Das habe ich glaube ich schon kapiert. Immerhin, wir sind
das beste Squad, ich habe 11 Kills. Bin ich zufrieden mit, weil es gibt kaum welche, die
mehr haben. Für so richtig einen Kack-Noop wie mich in dem Game ist es gut. Aber man
kann am Punkt spawnen, man kann aber auch bei den Leuten spawnen. Das klingt schon
mal sehr sinnvoll. Oh, der ist da stauner, Dude. Ich muss spawnen, Leute. Was, Deployment
in progress? Wie jetzt? Ah, jetzt. Oh, tactical sprint, please.
MonkaS, wo soll ich denn hin? Das ist mir viel zu hoch. Warum die den Scoreboard haben?
Ja, weil es denen scheiß egal ist, ob die Leute abfucken oder nicht. Und DICE hat sich
gedacht, ne ne, das geht nicht, wir können hier nicht. Alter, der geht nicht ins ADS.
Der Dude ist noch da, ich sag's euch. Der hat mich doch gesehen, der Kerl. Wer weg?
Ey, ich weiß gar nicht, warum ihr... Ah, friendly fire, friendly fire, na geil. Ge-friendly
und deploy. Lass mich rein. Leute, ich geh hoch, ich wette die Flanken hoch. Ich wette
mit euch die Flanken von oben hier unten rein. Oder auch nicht. Aber der tactical sprint
macht mich wirklich fertig. Ah, guck mal, da. Ein medikit. Huge. Ist da einer in der
Ecke? Findet ihr das auch ziemlich verschwommen auf range? Ist das vielleicht nicht auf max?
Doch, doch, passt, ist eigentlich alles gut. Die respawn cam. Ohne Mist, die respawn cam
ist viel besser als vom Battlefield. Du siehst wenigstens, wo du rein spawnst. Aber am Movement
müssen sie unbedingt noch was machen. Also das Movement ist wirklich richtig loss, ach
ne. Richtig pains, pains, champig. War da was? Hab ich da grad was gesehen? Hab ich da
grad einen Gegner gesehen oder war das einer von mir? Nee, das war wohl was von mir. Ja,
ich glaub die Beta kostet 13€ Early Access, aber ich hab das Spiel vor 2 oder 3 Jahren,
also schon ewig her, hab ich das auf Steam gekauft. Ich darf als Veteran mit 15 Minuten
Spielzeit oder so, als Veteran darf ich jetzt auch dran teilnehmen. Wir haben gecaptured.
So, wir haben den ersten. Leute, wollen wir mal LLV fahren? Land Drone haben wir. Guck
mal, wir haben. Gib ihm. Gib ihm. Gib ihm. Jawoll. Was ein Ding, sieht aus wie aus dem
Vincent's Door. Ach, wir haben nur beschränkte Range, ok. Man kann nicht steuern im Ironside.
Oh, da kommt der Pantsman, ich muss weg. Der real Pantsman ist am Start. Ok, gut. Nein.
Link Brocken. Nein, nein, Link ist nicht Brocken. Ich bin wieder da. Ich bin wieder in Range.
Ich hab, ich hab kein Ironside. Ich hab, mein Ironside ist weg. Warum ist mein Ironside
kaputt? Das ist ziemlich blöd, wenn mein Ironside kaputt ist, ich seh nix mehr. Ok,
was? Was? Oh, oh. Ha, da hast du gedacht. Das hast du dir so gedacht, Alter. Das hast
du dir so gedacht. Ich kann auch dieses Kocken abstellten hier. Wo ist er? Ok, ich hab ihn
hier. Ok, ich hab keine Ahnung, wo er ist. Ha, ha, ha. Im Kopf, Mann. Jetzt hat er sich
gedacht, er kann mich outmoven. Oh. Ok, ich hab nix gesagt. Was willst du machen? Was
willst du machen? Was willst du machen? Die Sprüche sind ziemlich tost, würde ich sagen.
Also ich kann ja nicht viele russische Schimpfwörter, aber das ist auf jeden Fall fast, fast, fast
schon in Richtung wie die Battlefield 3 Soldaten. Die haben ja auch geflucht ohne Ende. Eher,
das ist russisch tost, das ist kein Problem, das wird nicht gebannt. Englischsprachiges
wird auf jeden Fall. Was ist hier? Oh, da ist er. Alles klar. Kein Wort verstanden, aber
einfach gesagt, ich hab ihn richtig hart weggecockt. Keine Ahnung. Panzer? Nein, da ist einer.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Nein. Restore health, restore health. Nein, nein,
nein, nein, nein. Er schreckt mich nicht so. Da stehen unsere Leute in der Ecke und von
wo wärste weggeklatscht? Von hinten. Das Game hat definitiv keine Zwe- Doch, das Game
ist glaube ich schon 4 oder 5 Jahre in Entwicklung, aber ich glaube dazwischen hatten sie keinen
Bock mehr oder so, keine Ahnung. Fuck, jetzt hätt ich sie wegklatschen können. Achso,
Battlefield, nee, Battlefield nicht, Battlefield nicht. Leute, wir sind richtig gut, guckt's
euch mal an. Wir sind richtig gut. Gut, bock. Ok, wir stellzen wieder in der Tiefgarage
rum. Ok, wir sprinten, der kommt von oben jetzt. Ich weiß, der kommt von oben. Ah, alter
tactical sprint, man funktioniert doch halt. Ich hör so rumrennen, ich weiß nicht von
wo. Nee, das ist einer von mir. Dann sind die doch unten. Wer ist noch da? Jetzt nicht
mehr. Kann man sich hinlegen Leute? Hat jemand einen Plan, wie man sich hinlegt? Wow. Niemand
einen Plan, wie man sich hinlegt? Z? Nee, Y ist es nicht. Alter, Z. Wer ist denn auf
diese glorreiche Idee gekommen? Z. Ranker Z. Jetzt kommt was von hinten, pass mal auf.
Ich hör die über uns rennen, wir müssen jetzt tactical sprint, please, funktioniert
doch einfach. Jetzt hört er nicht mehr mal auf zu tactical sprinten, obwohl er aufhören
soll. Sag ich doch, dass ich was über mir flitzen hab hören. Nice Flitzer. Nice Flitzer.
Da kommt doch was unten, oder? Moment mal, da kommt doch was. Auf dem Radar ist genau
hier jemand. Seht ihr das? Genau hier ist jemand auf dem Radar. Hier. Genau hier. Invisible
cheat. Leute, ich würde ja mal gerne einen Airstrike holen, wofür brauchen wir den Airstrike?
Ich hol mal einen Airstrike. Wo könnte man einen guten Airstrike hinklatschen jetzt?
C2, äh C1, C1, perfekt. Oh, Predator. Da ist die Moab. Bäm. Haben wir was gekillt?
Es gab auf jeden Fall einen Hitmarker. Oder da fährt was. Oh. Au. Was haut er mir einfach
über den Kopf? Oder was auch immer das gewesen sein soll, ich weiß es nicht. Delta Modus
aktiviert. Da vorne ist ja auf jeden Fall was. Da hab ich gerade meinen Airstrike drauf
gejagt. Oh, wir haben wieder die nice Drohne. Bäm. Hallo? Rundstells. Bäm. Ich stehe halt
mitten, mitten auf der, auf der Map, ne? Das ist ziemlich dumm. Nimmt? Captured der?
Ne, der captured nicht. Au. Ach da. Äh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh.
Oh. Ha. Drohnenstells. Äh. Ach, Reloading. Au. Oh. Oh. Oh. Nice. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh.
Nice. Easy. Alter, wir haben richtig geowned. Ich glaub die Drohne ist OP. Guckt euch das
mal an. Die hält mehrere Panzer, Panzerfaustreffer aus. Und die two-hitted die Gegner. Sieht
man was? Ich hab Scoreboard, your squad best Scoreboard. Alter, 28. Richtig gut hier.
Pock. Wie von Zulu. Zulul ist ja Band Emote hier. Aber das ist, ähm, gar nicht mal so
schlecht. Gar nicht mal so übel, muss ich sagen. Level 4. Aber an die Movement müssen
sie auch. Oh, Schneiber. X6 HD am Stahl. Aber an der, also an die Movement müssen sie
auf jeden Fall irgendwas machen. Oh, guck mal, jetzt kriegen wir Griffs. Und aus irgendwelchen
Gründen Mini Tactical Laser. Customize. Equipment. Assault. Also Customization. Also das Holosight
haben wir am Stand. Was haben wir gerade Unlocked? Hier. ADS Time. Nee. Recoil. Nee, der Recoil
ist easy as fuck zu handeln. Das ist kein Problem. Der Spread und das Rumgewackele ist
eher problematisch. Underbarrel haben wir Unlocked. Classic. Okay. Darf man nicht.
Gibt's den Halo Multiplayer eigentlich auch kostenlaufender Konsole? Ja. Moin, erstmal
danke für das Dislaken. Wie ist das, WW3? Kann man als Battle, nee, Battlefield Ersatz
ist es definitiv nicht. Ich denke, das kann man so viel kann ich jetzt schon sagen. Es
ist eher so eine Richtung Rainbow Six Stels mit ein bisschen Battlefield. Es gibt Panzer.
Guck mal, wir können uns da reinsetzen jetzt. Wir fahren jetzt mal. Nee, ich darf nicht.
Ach so, weil Warm Up ist. Also wenn sie das, also die Maps und so, das erinnert mich tatsächlich
ein bisschen an Zen Crossing, findet ihr nicht auch? Das hat ein bisschen was von Zen Crossing.
Es sieht halt, die Maps sehen halt komplett leblos aus. Muss man jetzt halt auch mal sagen.
Das hat Battlefield 3 schon besser hingekriegt. Das Sound Kulisse ist, also die Waffensounds
und das Teufel finde ich okay. Aber das Movement müssen sie hinkriegen. Ich sage euch, wenn
die das Movement hinkriegen, dann kann ich mir das durchaus für Leute vorstellen, die
ein bisschen taktischeres Battlefield wollen oder die taktischen Modern Military Shooter
wollen mit ein bisschen Battlefield-Einschlag. Kann ich mir schon vorstellen. Wo sind denn
die Gegner? Die sind bestimmt da hinten irgendwo. Die Maps sind auch bei weitem nicht so groß
wie es beispielsweise eine Battlefield 2042 Map ist, aber sie sind halt eben relativ verwinkelt.
Ich meine, das hier könnte legit irgendwie so in irgendeinem Industriegebiet Berlin sein.
Klar, mich würde es sogar nicht wundern, wenn die sich nicht da irgendwo hätten inspirieren
lassen. He, he, he. Lull. Er ist Tactical Sprinter. Oh, wisst ihr? Guck mal, ich habe
ihm mit dem Helm runter. Habt ihr gesehen? Ich habe ihm mit dem Helm runter geschossen,
dem anderen. Bin gerade an der Agentur für Arbeit vorbeigelaufen. Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Real, Real Life. Real Life Schauplatz. Wahrscheinlich wohnen die Leute hier. Hier sind agile Start-ups.
Ja. Richtig agil. Sieht man hier schon. Was bitte? Ali hit? Angeblich habe ich gerade
ein Team-Mate gehittert, den ich oben ans Fenster geschossen habe. Oh, oh, oh, Team-Kill.
Weiß gar nicht, ob ich im Panzer Team Roadkills machen kann. Bäume umfahren und so geht glaube
ich nicht. Also die Maps scheinen mir relativ statisch zu sein. Man kann aber, das habe
ich schon, man kann durch Regale und so durchschießen. Also man kann durch dünne Wände
kommen man durch. Da hinten sind Gegner. Das ist nicht sicher. Guck mal, noch ein Panzer.
Okay, kaputt machen. Ah doch, Bäume umfahren kann man tatsächlich. Panzmann 2.0, wo sind
wir? Hier sind auf jeden Fall keine Gegner. Okay, Schussgefühl der Dinger ist Pains Champ.
Ein extrem Pains Champ. Trefferzonen gibt es eigentlich auch keine. Und ich kriegt den
Kill geklaut. Nice, GG Eats. Also Trefferfeedback Fahrzeuge ist mies. Ja, wir kommen aneinander
vorbei, nice. Oh, au, mein Ohr. Okay, das fliegt ja das Gehör weg mit. Mag es vielleicht
realistisch sein, aber es gibt so Realismus Sachen, die müssen in Spielen nicht sein.
Guck mal, hier wird gecaptchert, hier wird gecaptchert. Die werden jetzt gebasht. Die
liegen bestimmt hier in der Mitte irgendwo rum. Garantiert, hier irgendwo. Da ist er.
Okay, er ist down. Da hinten ist wieder was. Wenn ihr einfach mal mein Bahnkreuz funktionieren
würde. Alter, das ist doch nicht euer Ernst, oder? Das hört sich an, als knallt der Opa
die Garage zu. Der Opa knallt das Garagentor zu, so hört sich das an. Aber nicht nach
dem Panzer. Aber anscheinend haben die RPGs auch ordentliche Time to kill, also du brauchst
nicht drei Stunden die zu killen. Okay, pass auf, wir probieren mal was, wir probieren
durchzukommen. Lass mich in Ruhe. Wir haben weggestellt. So, Minipack aufnehmen. Ich finde,
das Healen dauert einen Ticken lang. Oh, hinter mir, hinter mir. Alter, kletter doch.
Ist der down? War der down? Oh, Tactical Sprint, man, funktioniert doch einfach. Muss mich
verpissen. Weil auf der anderen Seite sind sie ja auch. Oh, was ein Gewackel. Hier sind
bestimmt noch mehr, hier sind bestimmt noch mehr. Lass es mal meine Tuts machen. Oh, der
kotzt Leute, der kotzt ab, ich sag's euch. Der kotzt richtig ab. Alter, die kotzen richtig
ab. Oh, meine Schüsse sind gleich leer. Pass auf, Poggas, Poggas Schutz jetzt gleich.
Oh, die Pistole hat Travel Time. Das ist dumm. Nee, Pistolen kannst du vergessen. Also Pistolen
Nahkampf, no pass, no pass, aber ganz großes no pass. Hackert, ich bin gehackermant. Kann
man das aufheben? Ah, der ist despawned, der da. Was muss ich drücken? F? Okay, Pog.
Okay, ich renn jetzt, ich renn jetzt hier rein, weil ich hab. Nein. Oh Gott, Leute.
Richtige Noobies. Als wär ich jetzt hier der richtige Hardcore-Pro, ne? Achtung, Big
Brain Time. Big Brain Flank. Wenn Tactical Sprint gehen würde, Mann. Äh, wo, wo, wo
exactly ist hier was? Oh, wie der hackermant. Wie, ich hab nix gekillt? Seriously? Alter,
das verzieht ja mal richtig. Äh, ich guck mal, kann ich mich heilen? Ich vermute mal,
ich hab mich gehalten. Oh, oh. Wo, wo? Da, nice. Da is er down. Okay, nix wie um die
Eck, um die Eck. Das ist ja voll intense hier. Ist ja richtig anstrengend. Da muss
man ja richtig, muss man sich ja richtig Mühe geben. Passt es nicht. Guck mal, jetzt kommt
wieder von der anderen Seite was. Ich bin mir noch nicht ganz sicher, wann die gemarkt
werden. Das hab ich noch nicht gecheckt. Hier ist doch einer. Guck mal, genau hier ist wieder
einer. Oder ist der rote Punkt auf dem Radar etwa kein Gegner? Ich glaube fast die roten
Punkte sind keine Gegner. Sind keine Gegner. Die sind was anderes. Was auch immer. Nur
keine Gegner. Achtung, Heel stellst. Das mag ich. Der Heel könnte ein bisschen schneller
sein. Also das ist sehr langsam. Vor allem, weil du da drauf, weil du da runter gucken
musst. Und wenn du runter guckst, kannst du nicht, kriegst ja von der Umgebung nix mit.
Jaja, stellts weiter. Aber wir können die Big Brain Drohne losfahren lassen gleich.
Okay, hier rüber. Hier drüben sind sie. Ich lasse gleich die Drohne losfahren, wenn
ich weiß, wo die Gegner sind. Wow. Monarch. S. Ach guck mal, ich kann mir selbst Muni
geben. Ach nee, N ist der Feuermodus. Da kommt jetzt die Drohne. Achtung, Drohnen stellts.
Acht. Drohnen stellts. Drohnen stellts. Gib ihm. Huge Drohnen stellts. Die Steuerung ist halt
wirklich pain, pain. Richtig pain. Wo ist die geile Drohne? Oh, sehr gut, sehr guter
Winkel. Sehr guter Winkel. Schreckt. Schreckt. Die Drohne, man. Die Drohne ist so geil. Die
macht brutals Damage. Als sagen wir uns, die Steuerung ist ein bisschen gewöhnungsbedürftig.
Wo sind sie? Wo sind sie? Achtung, die Drohne kommt. Massive. Mini Panzer. Die Steuerung
ist wirklich äußerst gewöhnungsbedürftig. Aber seht ihr, die hat einen richtigen Spoiler
hinten drauf, die Drohne. Oh, ich bin down. Nee, nee, nee, ich lebe noch. Da steht er.
Oh, ich muss weg. Gegen den Panzer kann ich wahrscheinlich nichts machen. Halbes Hovercraft,
au. Nein, nein, nein, nein. Der schießt, der macht mich blatt, der Typ jetzt. Ich stehe
da mitten im Tor. Oh Gott, oh fuck. Ein bisschen mehr Zerstörung wäre schon cool. Ein bisschen
mehr Zeit. Oh, hallo, hallo. Hallo. Nein. Ich lebe noch. Das ist doch schon sehr behelfsmäßig,
die Drohnensteuerung gerade. Okay, wir gehen mal oben ans Fenster, falls es hier ein Fenster
gibt. Der Dude. Oh, genau zur richtigen Zeit hier. Ach, der hat auch keine Muni mehr. Shit.
Okay, nice. Wir haben jetzt ein. Wie war das? One shot, one opportunity. Grinch. Wer haben
wir nicht? Hat der hier was dabei? Oh, es piepst im Kopfhörer. Oh, macht das so gut
wie kein Splash Damage. Jetzt habe ich gar nichts mehr. Ja, das ist schön, wenn ihr
alle Medics seid. Jetzt habe ich gar nichts mehr. Ich kann keinen Gegner killen. Hat
der hier was dabei? Irgendwas? Haben wir ein Mehle? Messer? Irgendwas? Irgendwas? Was
ist Nahkampf? V? V, V. Okay, V ist Pains Champion. Wie soll ich den mit V ein killen?
Hier, da, da, da, da. Geh weg, geh weg. Okay, perfekt. Eats. Jetzt haben wir wieder was.
Z dort auf BG. Warum nicht? Warum nicht? Okay, wo geht's hier? Wo ist jetzt hier? Sekunde,
wir schauen mal Map. Was ist hinlegen? Z. Map. Kann man Marker setzen auf der? Nein.
Da unten sind sie. Und hopp. Oh, oh. Oh, KS, Alter. Wie findest du das Spiel? Das macht
erstaunlich viel Bock. Ihr 14 Kills die Runde schon. Alles wegen Drohnenstells. Das macht
erstaunlich viel Bock, aber ein Problem gibt es und das ist für mich so gravierend, dass
ich, nee, dass ich eigentlich fast keinen Bock hab, dass langfristig jetzt zumindest
die Beta zu spielen. Die Steuerung ist wirklich sehr, sehr verkackt. Also, der Sprinter nicht
richtig funktioniert teilweise. Das Hängenbleiben, das Rumgewackel, das Sliden und nicht richtig
aufstehen und, also, das fühlt sich nicht nach Gewicht an, das fühlt sich einfach
nach unfertig an. Aber okay, das ist ja auch eine Beta, das ist alles in Ordnung. War da
was gerade? Okay. Den Kopf. Moment. Zack, ist der nicht gestorben gerade?
Ich glaube, der ist dead. Deadge. Hört euch mal den Radio an. Ich will Radio hören. Wolfburg,
Stuttgart, Ingolstadt und München, habt ihr das gehört?
Bayern ist fast vollständig von feindlichen Truppen eingenommen. Bayern ist fast vollständig
von feindlichen Truppen eingenommen. Bayern ist fast vollständig von feindlichen Truppen
eingenommen. Truppen eingenommen. Oh. Maintenance 10 minutes. Oh, okay. But good job on the Beta
so far. Muss man mal ein bisschen nett sein. Move and Patch kommt. Wir passen auf, wahrscheinlich
Move and Patch. Auf geht's. Move. So, wind is quick. Ja, das machen wir. Wir winnen
das jetzt mega quick. Wo sehe ich überhaupt die Anzeige? Wann ist denn voll? Ist bei
1000 Schluss? Okay. Oh, guck mal. Blank, Leute. Blank action. The biggest flank of all time.
Den Heli brauche ich auch. Nee, nee, nee. Moment, Moment. Viel besser. Viel besser,
viel besser. Viel besser. The Pantsman kommt wieder. The Pantsman. Auf geht's. Oh. Okay.
Das ist natürlich dumm, wenn da einfach so ein fetter Panzer vor mir steht. The Pantsman
hat mich richtig weggehauen, ja. Den kann man nicht, den Panzer kann man nicht spawnen.
Aber wir gewinnen, wir gewinnen. Guck mal. Ich glaube 4500 muss man, muss man haben.
Das ist ein Gegnerpanzer, Mann. Gehst da weg. Wenn die Maintenance haben, dann können wir
uns den neuen Battlefield Patch angucken gleich. Slider end. Okay, keine Ahnung. Ich habe
einfach mal, ich habe einfach mal in die Richtung gehalten. Oh ja, krass, krasser Beat hier.
Catch him. Ich habe eine 1080 Ti. Oh, oh. Was ist der Panzer da? Oh. Alter. Was?
Paweczka. Paweczka. Oh ne. Der nächste Pantsman am Start.
Ich hoffe, der hat mich nicht gesehen. Oh. Wo? Wo ist der hin? Okay, ich habe Schiss,
die Street zu crossen, Leute. Doch, auf geht's. Tactical Sprint. Was, wir haben verloren?
Oh ne, loss. Ich camp mich mal kurz in die Ecke. Das ist dumm, dass man runtergucken
muss. Oh, oh. Ich habe es gleich gecaptured. Oh, oh. Mann, Alter. Oh, oh. Oh, oh, oh.
Alter. Alter, machen die einen Krach. Okay, wir haben es jetzt. Können sie nicht mal
spawnen. 5.000 haben wir gewonnen. Okay, 5k haben wir gleich. Oh, nichts wie weg. Move,
Alter. Tactical Sprint. Der Tactical Sprint ist halt überhaupt nicht tactical, da funktioniert
die Hälfte der Zeit nicht. Okay. Okay, Pantsman am Start. Pantsman am Start. Jawoll.
Pantsman in the ass, ass shooted. Die Steuerung von dieser Drohne ist wirklich krass. Ich.
Die Drohne ist so geil, Mann. Das ist so heftig OP, das Ding. Victory, easy, easy win. Dazu
kann ich nur sagen. Nee, du musst Veteran sein, das heißt, das Spiel vor 2 Jahren auf
Steam gekauft haben oder du kaufst dir für 13€ den Beta Access, wobei ich warten würde.
Ich würde wirklich abwarten. Wenn du das Spiel damals gekauft hast, Scoreboard. Guck
mal, es gibt ein richtiges Scoreboard. Wie ist das eigentlich möglich? Wo haben die
diese Technologie her? Wo gibt es die Technologie für Scoreboards? Also ich meine sicher, wenn
das so einfach wäre, hätte so ein großes Studio mit so einem riesen Publisher dahinter
wie DICE das auch gekonnt. Also das ist ja, das glaube ich, das ist absolut neueste Bleeding
Edge Technologie. Die Zukunft ist da, ja. Es ist ja 2042 hat man das halt nicht mehr.
Okay, die haben Maintenance. Wann haben sie Maintenance, sagen sie? 90 Minuten? Was haben
sie geschrieben? Ah, in 10 Minuten, 90 Minuten wäre Maintenance, okay. Ja gut, dann gehen
wir mal raus und warten mal bis die Maintenance vorbei ist und gucken uns mal eine Runde Battlefield
an. Ich muss das Game umstellen, wie der neue Patch ist. Battlefield 2042, fertig. Bam.
Also, kurz ein bisschen gedudel an. Nein, nein, nein, bestimmt nicht den Battlefield
Soundtrack. Viel besser. Weniger Hovercraft, okay also Patch, Battlefield Patch. Bevor
wir anfangen, hier, Battlefield Patch 2. Wir gucken mal schnell rein, was sich geändert
hat. Also, Hovercraft, Little Bird, Dings wurden adjusted. PPGar29 mehr Recoil, das
probieren wir gleich mal aus, ob die immer, weil ich mein, wenn sie der PP29 einfach
nur mehr so vertikalen Recoil gegeben haben, dann ist das überhaupt kein Ding. Dann kannst
du einfach runterziehen. Okay, Bullet Spread Reduced, wir probieren jetzt gleich mal, wir
probieren jetzt gleich mal Assault Rifles aus. PP29, Little Bird, Super Hockum, Overall
Minigun Land Vehicles, UAV in Bad Company ist wieder am Start. Breakthrough, haben sie
was an Breakthrough, haben sie was an den Blacks gemacht? Nee, das heißt Breakthrough
ist immer noch nicht richtig spielbar. Na gut. Dann schauen wir uns das doch an. Abgeschlossen.
Park Download Manager, auf geht's. Gehen wir. Ich muss jetzt gleich das Game Capture umstellen,
weil es immer, wobei Battlefield ging, Battlefield ging, im Battlefield hat ja nur im Menü geruckelt.
FeelsBadMan. Ich guck mal ein bisschen Chat, während das lädt. Wie gesagt Beta, man braucht
hier, 1 for 3 Steam. Nein, Battlefield möchte jetzt in den Vordergrund gehen. On Steam hat
man hier das Beta Pack für 13 Euro, wobei ganz ehrlich, hat man dafür überhaupt, ja
das sind irgendwelche Skins, braucht kein Mensch. Also, dass es ruckelt im Menü ist
normal. Auf geht's, Play. Dann spielen wir vielleicht gleich noch ein paar Runden. World
War 3. An den Flaggen, ob die an Breakthrough was an den Flaggen gemacht haben. Weil Orbital
war kacke, Kaleidoskop war kacke, Hourglass war kacke. Ach Leute, die Subz habe ich ja
komplett übersehen. Ja, ihr habt ja recht. Moment, Moment, Moment. Danke für die Subz,
wen haben wir hier am Start? Subze. Kaijit1. Gerhenrik. Pog. Sandpp. DavidsuStyle. Der
Taser hat verlängert. Aja ja, aber richtig hier. Ne, das war's. Und irgendwer hat gestern
gegiftet? Anygifters? 500 Bits, ja, hab ich nicht gesehen. Gönn euch Subz. Dankeschön,
wer hat denn hier gedodged? Alle erfolgreich gedodged, Leute hier. Außer JustSky, Ryukenshin,
Sandwich, Adonis, Adipo, Adipös. Also der quasi Pepofet Adonis. Defi und xPubot. Auf
geht's. Leute, das hat bis jetzt, iiih, mp9. Ok, mp9 ist ziemlich das dümmste, was du hier
spiele kannst, Ridiploi. Das hat so lange geladen, das Game. Bis jetzt, bis jetzt hat
es geladen. Ok, pp29, wir müssen es jetzt ausprobieren, Leute. Pip, lass mich please
hier spawnen. Sack, Sack, Sack, Sack, Sack, Testen, Sound, Display. Ok, stimmt alles.
Was denn hier? Die Sense fühlt sich schepp an im Vergleich zu dem anderen. Ich liebe
Battlefield 2042, who's? Wegschneibert. Mal gucken, ich bin mal gespannt, wie sich die
pp29 spielt. Gut, gerätzt werden wir hier nicht. Wir switchen mal, wir switchen mal
von der Ollen zu Crapling Man. Leute, ich hatte das Game übrigens zwischenzeitlich
uninstalliert, ne? Ich hab nur für den Stream wieder installiert. Ich hab gedacht, komm,
das können wir uns mal angucken. Oh, was ist denn da vorne los, man? Bisschen leise, oder?
Bisschen leise. Mal nen Ticken lauter hier. Ja, so ist besser, ne? Alles klar. Ja, das
Rätseln ist wirklich, äh, es ist rätselig keiner. Man selbst rätselt aber auch kaum.
Hier ist halt richtig klasse da. Warum spielen wir eigentlich gleich die schlechteste Map
zu Release, äh, zu, wir haben die Beta gespielt, die haben grad Maintenance, ja? Die haben
grad Maintenance, die haben sich sogar bei uns im Twitch Chat gemeldet und haben gesagt,
sie haben gleich Maintenance. Das Spiel ist so abfackt, da ist einfach so, da ist so viel
los, man. Gibt eh jeder Instant aus. Das hab ich schon gesehen in Patch 3. In Patch 3
kommt angeblich eine Ent-, oh, na, Mist. Eine Entfernungsanzeige für Medics und die
Medics können dich dann wohl angeblich auch pingen, dass du sagen kannst, ähm, ob sie
dich wiederbeleben wollen oder nicht. Okay. Darf ich jetzt mal irgendwie einen Gegner head
on sehen? Jetzt machen wir Big Brain Play, passt auf. Warum ist das Spiel eigentlich
zu broken? Jaja. Pass mal auf, vielleicht gehts jetzt. Hovercraft am Start, nice. Gefixt
ist, gefixt ist Hovercraft am Start. Ich schätze. Ist das Hovercraft wirklich gefixt, by the
way? Die Sache ist, oh, nice. Die Sache ist die, wenn der PP29 nicht mehr spielen kann,
was spielst du denn dann jetzt? Alter Mann, dieses Spiel, es ist, ich, es ist, ich war
ganz normal drauf, als ich das andere gespielt hab, ne? Aber kaum ist Battlefield 2042 am
Start, leg ich mich instant auf. Nee, MP9 auf die Range ist Müll. MP9 hat ausgewebt,
dann machen wir es doch jetzt mal anders. Dann nehmen wir doch jetzt mal Assault Rifle,
die hier angeblich dafür da sind, hier auf diese Range zu spielen. Sehr gut. Exzellent.
PoK, die hab, hab ich die schon? Hab ich die schon? Naja, gut, der Grappling bringt
ja grad gar nix. Geh mal hier rein. Oh, jetzt können wir Fliegestell machen, Leute. Ich
bin ein, wie hat letztens einer so schön gesagt, ich bin ein Ironsight-Enjoyer. Langer
Saks, Rest passt. Wollte jetzt eigentlich runter, hinterfliegen. Wollte eigentlich hinterfliegen,
aber ich, ich kann nicht abheben. Wir probieren mal, ob ich abheben kann. Okay, nop, nop, nop.
Gut, hier ist ja noch gar keiner. Oh, ein Rauf da. Ist Assassin's Creed kacke? Weiß
ich nicht. Ja, weil Haller ist sackig. Ich mein, das ist einfach nur flach. Halo ist
wirklich gerade am spaßigsten von FPS. Ja, ist wirklich so. Es ist einfach nur breite
Frontline. Äh, äh, ich hab die gerade durch, durch, durch, durch Air, durch die Luft erschossen.
Also nicht durch die Luft, durch, durch, durch das Ding durch erschossen. Habt ihr's gesehen,
die war eigentlich schon längst dahinter. GG Game. Ja, nice. Okay, irgendwie ist es
auch noch nicht viel nicer, sind die Assault-Rifles auf Range-on geworden. Oh, oh, oh, oh, Monarch.
Alter, die Assault-Rifles. Mit der alten PP-Gard 920 hätte ich ja schon drei Gegner gekillt.
Okay, oh, oh. Okay, das war PP-Gard von mir, da kann die Waffe wirklich nix für. Oh,
oh, oh. Nice. Äh, ich wollte eigentlich gerade die Scatternade schmeißen, aber ich hab den
Knopf nicht gefunden. Die Sturmgewehre gehen voll fit, das werden wir jetzt sehen, das
finden wir jetzt raus. Also mein Lieblings-Setup für die M5 ist ja das mit Schnellfeuer. Also
im Prinzip das da, da, Game, das da, das Game. Ist das verbackt jetzt? Ne, das hat sich jetzt
nicht so gelohnt. Okay, die müssen, die müssen ja hier irgendwo lang. Irgendwie da großartig
rumstellen ist hier unten hat ja so keinen Sinn. Vielleicht kann ich irgendwo hinfliegen.
Irgendwo sinnvoll. Oh nein, nicht hängen bleiben. Hängen bleiben ist gleich dead. Okay, hoch
kommt man hier nicht. Unka! Wieder einfach mal der Jet am Start ist. Oh, jetzt wird gepusht.
Puschke, Puschke. Puschke. Motion. Man ist halt dauergespotted auch in dem Game, ne. Da
hätte ich weiter wegspringen müssen, ich dachte es läuft weiter. Oh, Poggers. Ich mag
das Schnellfeuer Ding. Heil dich, heil dich. Knopf. Oh, da habe ich es ja von oben. Aber
gut, was willst du machen? Also ich muss sagen, ich habe tatsächlich das Gefühl, die M5 ist
ein bisschen genauer. Was richtig gut ist, weil die M5 mit Schnellfeuer macht auch richtig,
richtig gut DPS. Wie kommen wir denn jetzt hier am besten rauf? Was zum? Ah, okay, der
ist dead. Der ist ja dead schon. Hat man bloß nicht erkannt. Das Game hat sich gedacht,
nope, das spawnen wir jetzt nicht oder das despawnen wir jetzt nicht. Ich will eigentlich
auf der anderen Seite hoch, aber ich glaube, das funktioniert so nicht. Oh, ah. Okay, was?
Ach ja, aber dicke Spot XP. Was ist das für eine ppega Map? Das ist die beste Map in Battlefield.
Nein, die sucked hardcore. So wie fast alle Maps, aber das ist mit Abstand die schlechteste.
Game please. Nein, okay. Pants man. Hallo. Und Tschüss. Halfway to victory, aber gleich
ist die Base weg. Von wegen halfway to victory. Halfway to ppega eher. Was hintet mich denn
von der Seite? Geh weg. Geh weg. Ich meine, mit der pp920 konnte ich den Typ wenigstens
wegsprayen über die Distanz. Reds please. Reds please. Reds please. Ehrenmänner, Teammates.
Ehrenmänner, Ehrenerinnen und Ehrenfrauen hier. Please. Please. Battlefield 2042 in a nutshell.
Da machst du nix. Echt, das ist deine Lieblingsmap. Das kann ich nicht verstehen. Ich finde,
die sucked einfach nur richtig krass. Oh hier, bashen, bashen, bashen. Ja klar. Na klar.
Weil das auf Range auch so easy ist zu treffen. Alter, please. Kill die halt mal einfach.
Geile Waffe. Weißt du, die haben sich gedacht, wir machen riesige Ranges hin, aber Waffen,
die 5 Minuten brauchen Gegner über Ranges zu killen. Ich meine, ich spiele das Ding
jetzt auch nicht in dem Setup wegen der Schussfrequenz. Hat sich was verbessert. Ich habe bis jetzt
weniger Hovercrafts gesehen. Aber ansonsten, nee. Das ist einfach riesiges Terrain mit
nix. Ja. Büt, büt. Vielleicht, ich droppe jetzt auch einen Ranger. Ja, bam, Ranger.
Ranger drop. Ich weiß gar nicht, woran die jetzt gestorben ist überhaupt. Guck mal an,
was für riesen Fronten. Ok, da kommt ein Panzer. Da fliegt. Nice. Oh guck mal, ein Hovercraft.
Ich dachte, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh. Ok, vor dem Patch wären wir definitiv tot gewesen.
Vor dem Patch wären wir down gewesen. Das macht nicht mehr so viel krass Damage, oh,
oh. Das macht, also der Heli macht nicht mehr so viel Splash Damage wie vorher. Ist das
die Map mit den Pingui? Kann schon sein. Es ist auf jeden Fall die schlechteste Map im
ganzen Game. Nicht, dass die anderen wahnsinnig gut wären, aber diese wirklich doppelt, doppelt
und plus mies. Aha, ach nee, ich bin Spotter. Will kein Spotter sein.
Eigentlich macht es überhaupt keinen Sinn. Alles klar. GG Eats. Was, was Grinnt man in
Halo eigentlich so den Season Pass? Ansonsten, ich spiele auch nicht ranked. Ich spiele auch
bloß die ganz normale Playlist. Ok. Nice, wir fahren jetzt hier mit dem Typ.
Alter, beweg dich doch nicht so. Nicht so viel Moven. Nicht so viel Moven.
Ok, es macht, finde ich, ein bisschen weniger Damage, die Gatling Gun. Das sind keine Bots,
nee, das sind Spieler. Ich finde, die macht ein bisschen weniger Damage als vorher. Oder
die Spreader, die hatten mehr Spread oder so. Das kann auch sein. Würde gerne spawnen,
wenn das erlaubt ist, wenn das irgendwie möglich ist. Danke schön. Alter, was kommt denn da
für eine Lawine runter? Gachibass. Pass mal auf, kann man von hier starten? Vorgass.
Was ist World War 3? So eine Mischung aus Rainbow Six-Gestellte mit Battlefield-Einschlägen.
Wobei, es hat halt Movement aus der Hölle. Noch. Mal gucken, ob es besser wird. Ja, das
hat nicht so gut funktioniert, wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe. Guck mal noch mal hier
hin. War das nicht geplant? Ich merke das gleich, ich bin schon ein bisschen raus. Einfach
weil ich jetzt ein paar Tage nicht gespielt habe. Aber ich vermisse es ehrlich gesagt
auch nicht. Battlefield 2042 hier. Oh, guck mal hier, was er kann. Wie er nice. Ich meine,
wer hat sich gedacht, diese Waffen sind gute Range dafür? Wer hat sich das überlegt?
Wer hat sich gedacht, oh ja, die Assault-Rifles auf diesem Range, ja, das ist schon gut so.
Ich meine, es gibt ja nichts, was du auf diese Range gescheit spielen kannst. DMRs vielleicht.
Ich bin ein Ironside-Enjoyer. Und als Ironside-Enjoyer, aha, enjoyt man Ironsides. Aber die Visiere
würden es jetzt auch nicht großartig anders machen, bei dem Gewackel. Richtig, Männer
brauchen Ironsides. Richtige Schützinnen brauchen Ironsides. Please sterbt halt mal.
Nice Game. GG Eats. Es ist lächerlich. Es ist so hardcore lächerlich. Ja, die PP-29
wurde genervt und jetzt kannst du nichts mehr spielen über Range bei diesen Riesen-Maps.
Ob das jetzt so viel besser ist, bin ich mir da nicht so sicher. Hab da so meine Zweifel.
Oh. Ich hatte aber drei Gegner, egal mit wie viel Spread hätte es hitten müssen. Und
ich habe hier extra Rapid Fire genommen. Das kann es trotzdem nicht sein. Yeah, nice, easy,
verloren, yeah. Okay, vielleicht, vielleicht, oh nee, da fährt was rum. Alter, wie soll
ich denn, wie soll ich jetzt hier rüberkommen überhaupt? Ich weiß, dass neben mir was
ist, aber vielleicht schaffe ich es da. Probieren wir mal AKV 24 mit Extended Max. Okay. Ich
habe für die noch nichts frei gespielt. Probieren wir mal. Wir machen nochmal was anderes. Ich
gucke mal, ob das wirklich an meinen Attachments liegt, dass die nicht sterben. Ja, lass mich
rein hier. Perfekt. Nicht jetzt, genau. So, jetzt habe ich ja explizit den Range-Stellz
drauf. Alles klar. Oh Mann, Game, come on. Ich sage euch, ich aninstall gleich. Das ist
einfach so ein Crap. Ich habe die ganze Zeit Leertaste gespammt. Es hat einfach nichts
funktioniert. Aber vielleicht können wir das noch gewinnen. Also hier auf der Map,
hier geht es ja eigentlich. Hier kann man schön Dach stellen. Übrigens, es gibt einen
richtig geilen Trick. Gucken, ob ich den hinkriege. Wenn die hier reinpushen, wenn man sich hier
in die Ecke schießt, das klappt manchmal, dann bleibt man, wenn das Spiel der Meinung
ist, man darf, darf man da oben drauf stehen und es sieht keiner. Das checkt, das checken
die nicht. Wir können eigentlich Rapid Fire spielen. Machen das hier eigentlich? Effective
auf Range. Nee, wir müssen auf Range, müssen wir das hier spielen. Was kommt denn hier?
Was ist hier los? Wo wird hier gestellt auf der Map? Wo ist passiert überhaupt was gerade?
Ach, wir verlieren C2. Ja, das ist ja gut zu wissen. Aber C2 sollte wieder eingenommen
sein, denke ich mal. Man kann ja nicht zoomen und sieht nichts. Nee, C2 ist glaube ich vorbei.
Na klar. Wo kommt denn hier jetzt was an gerannt? Alles klar. Es ist explodiert, ich weiß nicht
mal von wo. Nicht bei Ansatzweise. Jetzt, jetzt sehen wir, ob es noch OP ist oder nicht.
Wir fahren jetzt eine Runde mit. Okay, da kann das genauso gut wie ich mit dem Hovercraft.
C2, gib ihm. Und raus hier. Ey, du sollst nicht so weit springen. Hab gehört neuer Patch
Rettet Battlefield. Oh ja, offensichtlich. Obvious Lee rettet das Battlefield. So, jetzt
sind wir close dran. Jetzt können wir auch mal ne Runde Dings hier spielen. Wir schreien.
Gatschi Buzz. Okay, okay, okay. Wo sind wir? C2. Wenn der C2 ist. Achtung, Achtung, jetzt
kommt Big Brain. Stonks. Ihr seht mich alle nicht. Ihr könnt mich nicht sehen. Unmöglich.
Unmöglich zu sehen. Unmöglich zu sehen. Kann man die PP29 wegwerfen? Nee, ich hab
irgendwie den Eindruck, also ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass die PP29 immer noch die
beste Waffe ist. Ich müsste das mal ausprobieren. Müsste das mal ausprobieren. Haben wir da?
Ich will kein Spotter sein im Tank. By the way, es ist übrigens normal in dem Game,
dass man permanent tot ist. Ist by design. Okay, ich glaube retten kann mich hier oben
keiner. Die MP9 ist auch auf Close Quarter ziemlich nice. Gerade mit, ja das ist das
richtige Mag. Also gerade mit diesem Magazin für ein bisschen mehr Schuss. Standardmäßig
hat es einen Ticken zu wenig Schuss, finde ich. Delsen wir mal rüber. Vielleicht kriegen
wir irgendwas weg. Da kommt was. Ey, warum ist das so verbugt, man?
Okay, okay. Ich bin in Ordnung.
Die checken es nicht, lull.
Oh, ein rotes Fass, rotes Fass, gefährlich.
Rotes Fass, ganz schlecht.
Rotes Fass, ganz gefährlich immer.
Oh, Monka, Monka, alles klar, ne, du hast keine Ahnung warum das die Leute so krass
hat, das siehst du doch hier, für einen Gegner den du siehst, seh' ich halt 20.
Das ist übrigens das beste Gebiet auf der Map, hier kann man das halbwegs spielen.
Ich mein, dafür kann ja ruhig jeder seinen Spaß dran haben.
Aber dann sich so zu stellen, ich verstehe nicht warum es die Leute haten, ich mein,
es gibt 30 Milliarden Videos die die Probleme erklären, die die Leute mit dem Spiel haben.
Also man sollte es zumindest nachvollziehen können, ob man das selbst dann Spaß dran hat
oder nicht, ist ja was anderes.
Aber ich glaube nachvollziehen sollte es nur mittlerweile jeder können.
Ja, die PP29 hat sich geändert und das Assault Rifles jetzt theoretisch einen Ticken besser
sind.
Theoretisch.
Oh, wir machen jetzt unsere Big Brain Tag, das ist zum Beispiel was was mich abfuckt.
Du siehst, du weißt nicht was abgeht, von wo irgendwas ist und bist down, ja beste, beste.
Kommst du her, komm her, kommt ihr her, kommt ihr her, irgend einer, Leute, das ist nicht
die Battlefield Experience.
Fuck, ich hab mich zu sehr bewegt.
Die Battlefield Experience war zwar immer nicht ganz übersichtlich, aber noch halbwegs
kontrollierbar und durchschaubar.
Das ist es einfach nicht mehr, das regt mich auf.
Deswegen kann ja jeder spielen, wenn er da Spaß dran hat, ich hab ja kein Problem, wenn
einer das Game spielt.
Ja, aber wenn du Videos gesehen hast, wo die Bugs drin sind, dann ist es ja offensichtlich
so, dass die Bugs existieren.
Dass du die nicht hast oder dass sie dir nicht auffallen, macht die ja nicht weniger existent.
Ja, die Hovercrafts sind jetzt nicht mehr ganz so krass und die PP29 ist ein bisschen
schlechter, mit mehr Recoil und die Assault Rifle sind angeblich besser.
Aber es ist immer noch im Kern, gleiches abgefucktes Battlefield 2042.
Was ist hier?
Ah, das ist ein Ranger, ok.
Nee, und spielbar ist das nicht, wenn man spielbar so definiert ist.
Man kommt in das Spiel rein und kann das genießen will ich nicht sagen.
Das kann rumlaufen und ein paar Gegner killen, das funktioniert, also die absoluten Basics,
die ein Multiplayer Spiel haben muss, die sind da.
Hätte man das vielleicht nicht als Battlefield angepriesen, hätte ich vielleicht sogar weniger
Schmerzen mit gehabt.
Was ist hier los, wir werden eh gleich von der Seite gebashed.
Alles klar, jetzt wissen sie, dass ich oben bin.
Hab ich eigentlich ordentlich FPS?
Ja geht.
PP29, ok die spielen immer noch alle PP29, ich mach das jetzt auch.
Ich mach das jetzt auch wieder und guck ob das wirklich, ob das wirklich so viel schlechter
ist.
So, gib ihm.
Oh, ich muss schnell sein, die sehen mich, oh, 50 Milliarden Gegner, 50 Milliarden Gegner,
50 Milliarden, 50 Milliarden, 50 Milliarden, 50 Milliarden, 50 Milliarden, 50 Milliarden,
was genau geht hier eigentlich ab?
Was war der Unterschied von Battlefield 1 zu Battlefield 5?
Naja, 2. Weltkrieg statt 1. Weltkrieg und ich glaube, ich glaube das erste war weibliche
Soldaten, wo es sich alle drüber aufgeregt haben, da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Da waren sie alle richtig, richtig nice getriggert.
Ich dachte nein, das darf nicht sein und by the way, warum kann ich hier nicht rüberspringen?
Also, hallo, ich möchte auf diesen, hier doch, ok, die zieht deutlich mehr, die PP29, die
zieht deutlich mehr, jetzt habe ich es gerade gemerkt, die zieht deutlich mehr jetzt nach
dem Patch rum.
Ich würde sagen nach links oben, nach links oben, könnte sein, hat sich gerade so angefühlt.
Ja, ok, ok, oh, wie hat der mich davon da gekillt, guck mal, der sieht mich noch nicht
mal, jetzt ist er nicht mal mehr spielbar, ja, das stimmt schon, man hat jetzt halt in
einem Spiel, was einfach hauptsächlich, also man hat kaum Waffen in diesem Spiel, die für
die Distanz gemacht sind, über die sich das Game abspielt, das ist sehr merkwürdiges
Design von den Battlefield Leuten, sehr, sehr merkwürdig, so, da steht irgendein Typ mit
der Gatling gun und ballert rein, nice, gepega aim, oh, ich will da nicht rein, hier ist
nichts, guck mal, hier ist einfach legit nichts, wo du rüberpushen kannst, hier ist einfach
nur randomized, guck mal, guck mal, es ist einfach flach, du kannst da nicht langlaufen,
einfach nur flach
ok, ich brauche Sundance mit den Granaten und was man auch hier dran sieht ist 128 Spieler
ist eine dumme Idee, ich meine, the fuck, wie soll denn hier irgendjemand noch was checken?
ich brauche die Sundance Granaten, sonst geht da nichts
guck mal, die aimen mich schon ab
also, ganz ehrlich, 64 Spieler hätten es wirklich getan und die Map ist einfach kleiner,
gut, mp9 funktioniert, wir müssen auf jeden Fall switchen, McCree bringt uns hier nichts
von Mobility, wobei hier jetzt McCree wirklich nice ist, komm, wir nehmen noch mal, nehmen
wir jetzt einfach noch mal, schnell Feuer dran, ja ja, alles gut, Ironside Enjoyer Max ist
wieder am Start, pass mal auf, wir machen jetzt Big Brain Move, obacht, weiß ich genau, wo
der hin ist, ist der down, wo ist der hin, also Massive Massive Move machen wir jetzt,
in der Hoffnung es funktioniert, ich höre mich nicht sehen, sind die oben, ich weiß
da, ihr weiß da halt auch nicht, sind die oben, sind die unten, kann man nicht, ich meine,
das ist der sittliche Mehrwert, dass man da oben hin kann, da ist tatsächlich einer,
dieses Spiel man, du kannst da wirklich rauf, gepega hoch drei alles, oh, gib ihm, gib
ihm, ok, ich wollte jetzt eigentlich, da ist, ja klar, easy, der Patch, ja, der Patch hat
jetzt dafür gesagt und gesorgt, dass die einzige Waffe, die man sinnvoll spielen konnte,
auf den Kampfdistanzen des Games nicht mehr gut ist, sehr gute Idee, richtig, richtig
gut, kann ich da rauf jetzt, ok, nice, beweg dich, ok, next please, ich weiß halt nicht,
wo da was ist, ich will eigentlich Big Brain Move machen, ok, der Big Brain Move geht anders,
das Problem ist, dass hier gerade zu viel los ist für Big Brain Move, der Big Brain
Move ist vollender, was, was, der ist nicht gestorben, lul, ey, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, da ist was, bin mir nicht so sicher, ob ich da, der Stream war schon
immer 48 FPS, ja, alter, Sniper, jetzt Sniper, ey, Game, was ist das, was ist das, das ist
doch nicht denjenigen ernst, warum sterben die nicht, ich weiß wirklich gar nicht, das
kann doch nicht sein, warum, warum stirbt man bei sowas nicht, das leuchtet mir, also
wirklich, dass man sich da wieder dabei gedacht hat man, und wir haben schon die Maximum-Damage-Variante
davon, ich konnte nichts machen, by the way, ich konnte nichts machen, jetzt ist das Game
angecrashed, geil, richtig geil, richtig gutes Game, das ist einfach so abgefuckt, ist was
andere wieder online, BF3, hey, ich hab ne Battlefield 3 Gameplay, Leute, das lad ich
demnächst hoch, Return to Battlefield 3, nicht, dass es irgendwie jetzt heißen würde, ich
spiel das jetzt täglich oder so, aber, komm, eine Runde probieren wir noch, ne, ich werd
heute wieder weiter Halo Cri'n heute Abend, in Portal bekommt man XP, ok, also eine Runde
will ich noch spielen, eine Runde machen wir noch, dann machen wir entweder WW3 weiter
oder ich geh was essen, ich hab Hunger langsam, mal gucken, während wir suchen, nicht Conquest,
während wir suchen, das ist ja der Witz, wisst ihr was, was auch ein richtig guter Indikator
dafür ist, dass es Broken-By-Design ist, Conquest ist eigentlich der bessere Spielmodus, auf
den Maps, aber dadurch, dass halt so ewiges rumgerenne und nix los ist, spielen die Leute
lieber komplett Broken Breakthrough, heute kam der Patch, der Patch, der alles gefixt
hat, ja, nein, es wurde im Prinzip nix großartiges gefixt, was das Spiel besser macht, ja,
warte mal hier, Steam-Stats, Battlefield 2042, gucken wir mal, BR4, ich mein, das ist nicht
wirklich repräsentativ, ne, das ist Battlefield 4, das ist nicht wirklich repräsentativ,
weil Origin und Konsolenspieler und so, aber die haben halt schon mal einfach 50% ihrer
Spieler verloren, in, keine Ahnung, in den ersten zwei Wochen, was sagst du zur Roadmap,
ganz ehrlich, das was ich noch am interessantesten finde, bei der Roadmap ist, dass es Rush in
Portal gibt, aber wenn die gleichen Leute, die Breakthrough fahren, platziert haben Rush,
Encoms platziert haben, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein,
nicht our Breakaway, ganz bestimmt nicht, ganz bestimmt nicht, was wollte ich jetzt
sagen, ja genau, also und, genau Rush und die 150 Fixes für die Maps, auf die bin ich
auch gespannt, ob die die Maps halbwegs spielbar machen, ich persönlich fürchte nicht, zumal
die Sache halb die ist, die müssten jetzt ja eigentlich richtig krass mal rankommen
mit Content Drops, die müssen ja das Spiel exciting halten, wie man so schön sagt heutzutage,
aber die sind ja gerade aktuell damit beschäftigt, komplett das zu fixen irgendwie, also das
ist so ein zweischneidiges Schwert, ja, du musst das Spiel fixen, weil ansonsten rennen
die Leute weg, wenn du kein Content bringst, rennen die Leute aber auch weg, oh Gott, ist
das euer Ernst, erst kommt Breakaway, jetzt kommt Our Class, die zwei schlimmsten, schlechtesten
Maps hintereinander, ja gut, gut sichtbar alles hier, ja sehr gut, übrigens ist auch
ein Kritikpunkt, den es gar nicht bis in mein Video geschafft hat, ich finde die Fahrzeuge
zum größten Teil mega lame, also klar ist das manchmal richtig OP, aber ich finde die
Fahrzeuge an sich langweilig, erinnert euch noch dran, was das so richtiges Helimeter war,
wo du unter dem Radar nimmst in Battlefield 4 und Battlefield 3, oder ob du irgendwelche
anderen Lowdots, so Heatseeker nimmst oder sonst was, so ein richtiges Fahrzeugmeter,
das existiert nicht, Panzer Attachments sind eigentlich auch zum größten Teil totaler
Crap, das schlechteste Panzer Attachments ist die Shotgun, es gibt so ein Shotgun als
Panzer Attachments, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das schon mal gesehen habt, das ist einfach
nur richtig pepega, das killt nichts, das ist auch über die Range, da kannst du halt
nicht mehr drauf schießen, nice Game, sehr gut, Poggers, ganz großes Kino, der durfte
nicht sterben, nicht sterben, kein Ding, Shotgun 0, ja die Shotgun ist angeblich jetzt auch
besser, habe ich gelesen, ach nee, Moment, Moment, sie haben für alle den Spread reduziert
außer die Shotgun, nee das stimmt nicht, weil ich gesagt habe, die Shotgun ist genauso
gut oder fast, fast useless wie vorher, das capturen die, da rennen gerade 40 Leute drauf,
kann mich nicht entscheiden Leute, ja natürlich ist das Aim nicht wirklich on point, wenn
du da 50, ich habe den Gegner nicht mal gesehen durch den ganzen Rauch, aber trotzdem, ihr
habt die Hitmarker gesehen, ich komme, ihr habt die Hitmarker, der ist zwar ver-aimed,
ja aber ihr habt die Hitmarker gesehen, der hatte bestimmt 5 Hitmarker, die Katze ist
richtig, oh hier darf ich ja nicht hin, ich habe es ganz vergessen, achja, ja kill mich,
alles gut, ok, Hourclass spielen wir nicht Leute, Hourclass spielen wir nicht, irgendwas,
so vielleicht, vielleicht Manifest, Manifest, ich gebe mir ja sogar kein Leidoskop meinetwegen
noch, aber please, nicht Breakaway oder Hourclass, Praege Leute, Praege, Praege, was kommt,
Kaleidoskop, ok, ok, die kann man spielen, hier unten steht übrigens die Map, weil hier
war zu wenig Platz, wisst ihr, dieses leere Feld hier in der Mitte, da war zu wenig Platz
die Map anzuzeigen, Custom Load Sequenz für eine Map zu machen oder so, das geht nicht,
echt du magst Manifest nicht, ich mag Manifest, ich mag sowohl den Containerhafen als auch
oben das auf dem Berg, was genau hat eigentlich dieses Schiff mit dem Spiel zu tun, fällt
mir gerade auf, was hat das Schiff im Ladebildschirm und das Schiff im Intro eigentlich mit dem
Spiel zu tun, es gibt in dem Spiel überhaupt keine Schiffe, es gibt Hovercrafts, ach die
Story von Irish, ja das kann sein, aber es gibt es halt im Spiel nicht, hat halt, hat
halt mit dem Spiel nichts zu tun, es gab einen Kurzfilm, ja super, es gab einen Kurzfilm
mit einem Schiff, aber es gibt, das ist ja auch schon mal wieder widersprüchlich, es
gab einen Kurzfilm mit einem Schiff, aber es gibt kein einziges Schiff im Spiel, außer
das auf, ähm, äh, wie heißt das D-Dings, deconstructed, ne wie heißt die Map, mit
dem kaputtenen Containerschiff, Songdo, wir sind Attacker, das ist schon mal ganz gut,
ja, wir striken richtig, discarded, genau, deep lore, die unfassbar vielen DLCs von Battlefield
5, wie viele Handbilder von Battlefield 5 haben wir am Ende jetzt gehabt, einen, einen,
die Pacific Maps, ja du kannst die Map nicht gewinnen als Attacker, ne ne, werdet ihr auch
gleich sehen, dass man die Maps nicht gewinnen kann, oh oh, ich bleib mal kurz hier drin
genau, da, da, da passt, ok, was, alles klar, game, das hat gut funktioniert, was zum,
das war die Messer-Animation, oder, dass ich die nicht killen durfte, ich glaub das war
die Messer-Animation, echt, du hast es geschafft hier, was, wirklich, ich hab noch nie einen,
einen Attacker-Win erlebt hier, dachte das ist gar nicht möglich, kein Ironside-Enjoyer
mehr, hat sich ausenjoyed, und wir haben A2, nice, easy, ok, auf die Range brauche ich
was anderes, ah, One-shot-Sniper, bashen, alter, bashen, naja, aber Motion-Sensor ist
gut, weil Motion-Sensor immer gleich fett XP, ich bin tatsächlich richtiger Ironside-Enjoyer
in so Games, also ich sag euch, wie das, das war zwar ver-aimt, am Anfang, am Battlefield
3, wär der gestorben, instant, noch, mit einem M16 oder MP16-Burst, na guck mal, da
willst du was anschleichen von hinten, was ist hier, was soll das, ok, ich seh ihn nicht,
ich seh ihn nicht, ich hab keinen Plassen-Schimmer, wo er ist, oh, da ist ein Auto, ok, nice, M16,
weil die M16 war halt broken as fuck in Battlefield 3, aber, die haben es trotzdem hingekriegt,
obwohl es quasi eine universell beste Waffe eigentlich in fast allem gab, also Allround-mäßig,
mit fast besten Stats in fast allen anderen Stats, mit der M16 haben sie es trotzdem
geschafft, dass es competitive war, was anderes zu spielen, du konntest der AEK spielen, du
konntest der M416 spielen, du konntest der M490 spielen, wenn du das gut konntest, ach,
ich find's so gut, dass die Leute sterben über Range, was gab's denn noch, AS Valkons
zu spielen, aber das war ja so ein allgemeines Ding, was hat's noch, also AK war in Battlefield
3, hat er halt gesagt, AEK M16, M416, F2000, F2000 war ein bisschen AEK für Arme, ja,
das stimmt, aber was ist hier los, ist halt auch einfach alles flach, wie das Game nach
dem Patch läuft, im Prinzip genauso schlecht wie vorher, ach, war die F2000 DLC Waffe, da
kann ich mich nicht mehr dran, oh, jetzt wollte sie mich retten, da kann ich mich nicht mehr
dran erinnern, ob das DLC Waffe war oder nicht, P90, oh ja, P90 war mega poggers, P90 war
mega poggers, hier ist alles wieder so flach, man, was willst du hier machen, schön gespottet,
oh, oh, any spotters, es ist einfach nur komplett flach, Farmers, nee, Farmers fand ich nicht
so geil, Farmers fand ich jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig, nice, ach guck mal, wir haben A1, ok, da ist
wieder alles wie gedacht, man passt wieder, ich meine das geile ist ja, dass diese Ranges,
diese Range ist quasi mal mit Noshah Canals betrachtet, das wo ich jetzt gelaufen bin ist
Noshah Canals vom Meer bis zu den Bahnschienen, oder waren das Bahnschienen, das war Noshah
Canals Meer bis zu den Bahnschienen, das war die komplette TDM Map, die ich gerade gelaufen
bin, so einfach mittendrin in der Runde, ohne dass es irgendwas besonderes war, und hier
ist auch wieder komplett offen, Moment, wir müssen unsere Granaten umschalten, ach nice,
ist kaputt, es wäre eine Frechheit die Seasons zu starten bevor das Game gefixt ist, sagt
der Chat, ich glaube den wird nichts anderes übrig bleiben, die müssten die Seasons starten,
weil du hast im Prinzip ja zwei, hier kann man hoch, interessant, Pog, ich blinke Leute,
ich blinke, warum blinke, ich wurde Gehackermann, die haben ja im Prinzip nur die Auswahl zwischen
Pest und Cholera wenn man so will, die können das Spiel erst komplett fixen und dann rennen
die Leute weg, die es jetzt spielen weil es kein Content mehr gibt, oder die bringen
Content und alle regen sich auf, dass keiner fixt, also im Prinzip können die es gar nicht
richtig machen, und das ist das Problem wenn du in so einem Zustand launchst, du musst
jetzt nicht nur fixen was eh immer zu machen ist und neuen Content liefern und das pünktlich
und das möglichst schnell, nein, du musst auch erst noch mal dein Game fertig entwickeln
und das ist halt echt schwierig, die sind jetzt quasi schon, die sind ja im Prinzip
ein halbes Jahr hinten dran mit ihrem Spiel durch diesen Zustand jetzt, und das stelle
ich mir, ich stelle mir das wirklich, guck mal wie lange das dauert, das stelle ich
mir echt äußerst schwierig vor, der Content ist schon produziert, da bin ich mal gespannt,
woher weißt du das, also redest du das oder haben die das gesagt, was kann ich sagen,
ja seh mal das Spiel produziert, lull, das haben die gesagt und dieser tolle, du meinst
ja den Tom Henderson, also wenn der Content schon produziert ist, in diesem Zustand wie
der Content jetzt ist, dann gute Nacht, sag mal sterb halt mal Mann, ja, das mit den
mehreren Entwicklerstudios, das ist ja auch meine Vermutung, dass sie das versucht haben,
möglichst parallel, also die mehreren Entwicklerstudios ist so mein Ansatz, warum es überhaupt drei
verschiedene Spielmodi gibt, dass du die vielen Leute überhaupt parallel irgendwo hinbringen
kannst, aber dass es nicht funktioniert, hat man ja am Release des Spiels gesehen, also
für das Geld, was die haben und für die Manpower, die die haben, ist der Zustand schon echt
mies, ich sag doch gar nichts Panda, ihr wisst doch, ich bin eh Fan davon, dass die Leute
ihre eigene Meinung haben dürfen, auch wenn ich der Sache nicht zustimme, ich muss euch
ja nicht zustimmen, aber es ist ja überhaupt kein Problem, wenn ihr irgendwie eine andere
Ansicht seid, ich hab mir da keine Schmerzen mit, solange ihr nicht sagt, Max ich fick
deine Mutter, du Kackspaß, dann ist alles in Ordnung, dann hab ich keine Schmerzen mit,
weil einer etwas anderes meint als ich, man sieht auch so gut was hier, ein Toss, ich
hab Hunger, die Runde machen wir noch fertig, aber danach gehen wir was fuddern, Flugstells,
kann man von hier abheben davon, für den nächsten finde ich tatsächlich Webster ziemlich
gut, weil man sich da in die Galerie rein hucken kann, ja ich hab ja auch gesagt in
meinem Video, das Game hat durchaus seine Momente, ich bin immer noch ein bisschen unschlüssig,
ob es wirklich so gut war das Battlefield zu nennen, also gut, das verkauft sich, was
sollen sie sonst machen, ich wollte eigentlich fliegen, ich darf nicht fliegen, also für
mich, ich hab es ja mal im Video gesagt, für mich hat das nicht so wirklich das Gefühl
von Battlefield, siehst du einen, seh'n dich 5, Frosch68, bist du der Frosch von YouTube,
aber argle, aber argle null, oder irgendwie sowas, oder heißt du nur zufällig Frosch,
oh Big Flank, Big Flank, ja klar, eh klar, perfekt, das ist der richtige echte Frosch,
Big Flank, und wisst ihr was Big Flanks in dem Spiel bringen, gar nichts, gib ihm, gib
ihm, jaja ist gut Panzer, jaja Panzer, ist gut, kriegt euch ein Mann, kriegt euch ein,
ich verpiss mich mal, ich bin raus hier, oh da steht ja wieder was auf der Gasse, Hell
Jesus ist am Start Leute, Hell Jesus, aber Hell Jesus sieht nichts, Hell Jesus ist komplett
blind, hallo ich möchte Waffe wechseln please, danke, nice game, GG Eats, ok hier darf man
wieder nicht springen, ah Midipack, oh Girls, so ein Motionball da hinten in die Ecke, ich
würde den ja retzen, das Dumme ist, ah der hat schon gecancelt, oh Leute, abfuck, 12
kills 21 assists ist schon eine gute Runde in dem Battlefield, nein nein nein, ach Mist
ich wollte ja gar nicht mit der spawn, ziehst du 2, sehen dich 15, jo echt so, ja ja sehr,
high speed wingsuit, ok Achtung, das Schlimme ist halt, dass die selbst außerhalb spawnen,
die spawnen auch da hinten, das sackt halt mal richtig, ist das ein Schneiber, ups das
war gar keine, ah, in the cop, da ist doch was, hier ist doch angeblich was, das ist
gar kein Sniper oder, das ist gar kein Sniper, das ist einfach nur ein Scheinwerfer, Keg
mit, boah, weggerotzt, so jetzt spawnen wir mal mit dem anderen, meistens ist hier schon,
ist hier schon fertig, aber man kann, also die nächste Sache ist nicht einnehmbar, aber
das hier kann man schaffen, das kann man einnehmen, das andere, das andere ist nicht schaffbar,
achja, nice, jetzt gehen wir fliegen, was ist da, war das, das war nur die Kiste die
ich gehittet habe oder, nicht der Typ selbst, von vorne kannst du halt auch nichts machen,
das ist so offen man, das ist so offen einfach nur überall, pass auf, ich wette mit euch
bald kommen sie auf die Idee hier C4 runterzuschmeißen, auf die Idee sind sie ja bis jetzt noch nicht
gekommen, aber das dauert nicht lang, ok, jetzt machen wir, ja wir haben das dran, krieg
dich alter, ich krieg dich, come on, the demon mantis, einfach mal reinspringen, einfach
mal reinspringen, da war doch links auch noch was, oh habe ich wiederbelebt bug, kann das,
habe ich wiederbelebt bug, nee, ach nee, das ist dieser, dieses komische rumgebagge, jawoll,
gibts mir, easy gachi pass, jawoll, Spritze rein, Booster Impfung am Start, Booster ist
raus, schuldig, schuldig, was ist das hier, Moment, wo ist hier, wo ist hier oben und wo
ist unten, wir haben es Leute, wir haben es, mal ab aimen falls hier irgendjemand rein will,
mal schauen, der stellt es doch hier noch, war doch klar, oh wir haben kaum noch, kaum
noch money, nice, so jetzt müssen wir irgendeine Waffe finden, die hier vielleicht noch rum
liegt, da stellt sich eine Waffe, gib ihm, 15, 15, was ist das, mp9, ich nenne auch eine
mp9 mit drum mag, hatte ich noch nie, keine Ahnung ob das was taugt, mp9 drum mag, auf
gehts, die sind halt immer noch da oben, was sagt der neue Patch, pp 29, wird nicht mal
so oft gespielt, hovercraft ist ein bisschen genervt, aber ansonsten hat es am Battlefield
nicht allzu viel geändert an 2042, so wir haben noch, ach das ist schon der letzte Punkt,
ja jetzt schaffen wir, also Leute jetzt ist die Map vorbei, jetzt ist die Map vorbei,
also C1 geht noch, C2 ist nicht einnehmbar, guckt euch mal die Motion Sensors an, wie
viele Motion Sensors hier rumfliegen, keck w, Dankeschön dass man nicht drüberspringen
darf, ach das war der Typ noch in der Ecke dabei, gibt doch noch ein Fahrstuhl, ja es
gibt, passt mal auf, das müsst ihr gesehen haben, das ist wirklich Map, aber wirklich
Massive Big Brain Map Design in Reinform, also besser gehts nicht, fährt er hoch, 30 Stunden
Reload Zeit, oh da ist ein hovercraft, wenn ich Reloaded hab, wenn ich Reloaded hab dann,
ok wir habens, so und jetzt passt mal auf Leute, wir müssen jetzt, alles klar, wir müssen
jetzt auf das Dach hoch, also du kannst, wie haben sie es denn bei Orbital gemacht, du
meinst dass du von mehreren Seiten mit der Zip Line hoch kannst, ja bei Orbital ist eigentlich
auch nicht einnehmbar, Orbital ist auch nicht einnehmbar, guck mal da links, das geht hier,
was geht hier, so du hast zwei Varianten, ich zeige euch, Mensch hovercraft, ah der versucht
hoch zu fahren, ok, du hast zwei Sachen, du kannst hier mit dem Fahrstuhl, wo ist denn
hier der Fahrstuhl überhaupt, hier, du kannst hier mit dem Fahrstuhl hoch und dann rüber
Zip Line oder bei dem anderen mit dem Fahrstuhl hoch, das Problem ist jetzt, ihr werdet es
gleich sehen, ihr werdet es gleich sehen, also was anderes fällt mir da wirklich nicht
zu ein, oh guck mal, ich werde wiederbelebt, ok, vielleicht schaffe ich es noch mir was
rein zu drücken, wir machen jetzt Trick 17, ich flieg jetzt, ich flieg jetzt, pass mal
auf, ich flieg jetzt woanders hin, sobald die Tür aufgeht, guckts euch an, ich hab's
versucht, ich wollte den Big Flank machen hier, aus der Tür raus, nehm das Schild,
das hört sich in der Theorie gut an mit dem Schild, aber da wird so viel reingespampt,
das kannst du vergessen, selbst wenn du schildert, du kriegst ja nicht mal tot, wer hat sich
denn sowas ausgedacht, ja irgendwas mit schwedischem Name auf jeden Fall, irgendein 3-Head Schwede,
achja man kann auch in das andere Haus übrigens rein, wir gucken uns das jetzt mal, ok, wir
machen das jetzt von der anderen Seite, Achtung, wir können nämlich auch hier in den Fahrstuhl
rein, so wir können nämlich auch hier rein und hier hochfahren, so, das ist nämlich viel
besser, das ist nämlich viel besser hier hoch zu fahren, weil wenn man hier hoch fährt,
dann passiert nämlich gar nichts, guckt hier, das easy kommt man raus und basht alles, ach,
hm, ach guck mal da steht sogar ein Hovercraft auf dem Dach, achja und das Hovercraft hebt
gerade ab, das ist einfach in die Luft geflogen gerade, die hat gerade gesagt, our victory
is imminent, ich, hm, x, x daubt, wir overwhelmen die überhaupt nicht, das stimmt nicht, das
Gamer zählt einfach Stuss, ok, ja das war zu viel spread, das war zu viel spread, ich
hab das auf, oh oh, oh oh, ist aber mal gut ey, Transportheli von oben, ja das funktioniert,
aber im Prinzip wirst du eigentlich schon gebashed, während du runterspringst, es ist
halt äußerst, ach Leute, der Ansage, jetzt hab ich's verstanden, der Ansage hat's gesagt,
wir müssen nur noch das final objective taken, dann gewinnen wir, ach so, jetzt weiß ich
auch was ich fast falsch mache, just take the final objective, Mensch, wie hab ich, warum
hab ich das so lange nicht gesehen, Achtung, wir fliegen jetzt wieder wohin, da steht ein
fucking Panzer auf dem Dach und schießt in den Fahrstuhl rein, ein Panzer, ein Panzer
steht auf dem Dach und schießt, ach Gott, das ist so schlecht, die sollen AC, die sollen
hier Leute, wisst ihr was die machen müssten, die Attacker, wisst ihr was die Attacker machen
müssten, ich zeig's euch, Sekunde, wenn meine Maus funktionieren würde, die Maus
müssten das hier machen und einfach alles wegsprengen, was da oben drauf steht, by the
way, dass das nach drei Wochen immer noch nicht hotfixed wird, wurde hier dieses Objective,
ein absolutes Armutszeugnis, das sollte das einfachste sein, von der Welt so eine publische
Flagge umzusetzen, hat das Ding hier nicht auch Fahrstühle irgendwo, Moment, hat das
Teil hier nicht auch Fahrstühle, ne Jonas hat keine Fahrstühle, doch hat Fahrstühle,
oh der kommt gleich, guck mal, oh der kommt, wegen der, die kommen runtergefahren, da kommen
gleich Gegner raus und tschüss, die fahren jetzt schon runter, welches Herz dann empfiehlst
du, das einzige Herz, das ich empfehlen kann, ist das Spider-Nexx MMX300, kannst du C4 in
das mal an, da ist die gesamte Grundschule auf dem Dach, das ist eine richtig gute Idee
gewesen, C4, da muss ich ja C4 werfen, C4 im Fahrstuhl selbst sind die glaube ich nicht
nah genug dran, hätte man jetzt einen Mörser wie in Battlefield 3, ja, ach fahr mal nochmal
hoch, ich probiere das mal, ich probiere das mal mit C4, man könnte C4 hier hinlegen und
sich selbst, und sich selbst in die Luft sprengen, oh man, das ist nicht Battlefield, das ist
demlichstes Design aus der Hölle, so, wo ist der C4 überhaupt, hier, sind wir oben,
sind wir oben, sind wir oben, ne oder, ne, ne, ne, ich habe C4 glaube ich noch nicht
einmal ausprobiert hier, oh der Shieldman, ok, wie machen wir das hier, ne, der Shieldman
hat doch keinen Bock mehr, ok, doch jetzt hier, ist das C4 gerade in die Luft geflogen
als der Fasche losgedingst ist, das C4 ist in die Luft geflogen als der, oh, ich dachte
wir müssen, ich dachte wir müssen just, just einfach nur noch das objective, das final
objective captchern, dann war es das, cringe Sprüche, die Sprüche sind so dumm, die Durchsage
meinte, dass wir gewinnen, achja, 182, ok, boah, ey, alter, dieses Game, man, boah,
der erste Typ hat das letzte Emblem für Hovercraft, ja, wundert mich nicht, manche
Leute haben das Hovercraft ja nix anderes gespielt, seit, seit, im Prinzip, seit Early
Access start, fahren die quasi permanent kreisel mit dem Hovercraft, was hältst du
von World War 3, ich muss sagen, ich fand es gar nicht schlecht, das Movement ist aber
top, komplett abgefuckt, ja, ich würde den Streamer Mikro Tick up, hier, genau, oh man,
ja ne, es war Stream, Leute, ich gehe jetzt was futtern, wir sehen uns, bis dann, macht's
gut, tschüss.